ओके
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आई थिंक आई एम
लाइव
अ आई थिंक आई एम लाइव राइट
या ओके सो वी आर लाइव नाउ अ प्लीज लेट मी
नो गाइस ऑडियो वीडियो सब कुछ सही है एक
बार बताइए जल्दी से सभी लोग सभी लोग फटाफट
बता दीजिए ऑडियो वीडियो एवरीथिंग इज फाइन
गाइस
गुड इवनिंग टू एवरीबॉडी।
नमस्ते।
नमस्ते एंड गुड इवनिंग टू एवरीबॉडी।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] ऑडियो वीडियो सब
एकदम बढ़िया टकाटक।
ओके।
ओके। चलिए अच्छी बात है।
ओके। चलिए। सो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
आज की सेशन हम स्टार्ट करते हैं। बस
विद इन अ मिनट वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग।
सेंट मैंगो लस्सी फॉर टू ज्वेल्स। वाह!
मैंगो लस्सी भेजा है। धन्यवाद।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
मैंगो लस्सी। बढ़िया बात है। अच्छी बात है।
धन्यवाद आप सभी को।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए। सो
गाइस बिफोर वी स्टार्ट लेट मी क्लियर
सम थिंग्स। आज की जो सेशन है यह भी एक ऐसी
सेशन होने वाली है जहां हम फिशिंग के
कंप्लीशन की तरफ बढ़ेंगे। जो कि एक काफी
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट
एक टॉपिक है आपके एसओसी एल1 सीरीज की।
आपको इसके बारे में नॉलेज जो है वो प्रॉपर
होनी चाहिए क्योंकि एसओसी एनालिस्ट के तौर
पर एल1 के तौर पर आप फिशिंग एनालिसिस
प्रिवेंशन इन सबके लिए रिस्पांसिबल होते
हैं। मतलब फिशिंग के बहुत सारे केसेस आपको
देखने को मिलेंगे। जब आप कॉर्पोरेट में
जाते हैं। यू विल सी अ लॉट ऑफ़ अटेमप्ट्स
एंड केसेस। राइट? सो बिफोर वी स्टार्ट,
मैं आपको एक चीज बस बताना चाहता हूं। बहुत
बड़ी चीज है। हालांकि मैंने ऑलरेडी
इनफॉर्म तो करा है बट स्टिल डिफ्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी YouTube चैनल आप सर्च करेंगे
डिफ्रॉनिक्स YouTube पे आ जाएंगे आप। ठीक
है? यहां वीडियो सेक्शन में जाएंगे जब आप
तो आपको यहां पे एक वीडियो मिलेगी फ्री
साइबर सिक्योरिटी कोर्सेंट अनाउंसमेंट। आई
वुड रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी टू प्लीज वॉच दिस
वीडियो और इसमें आपको एक WhatsApp ग्रुप
का लिंक मिल जाएगा। स्पेशली इस पर्टिकुलर
कोर्स के लिए वह आपको जॉइ करना है क्योंकि
इसमें बहुत सारी चीजें कुछ-कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
चीजें बताई हैं वह आप सुन लीजिएगा। बहुत
छोटी सी वीडियो है 6 मिनट की वीडियो है।
एंड क्योंकि हम एक प्रॉपर एथिकल हैकिंग की
जो वन शॉट वीडियो कोर्स है उसका पार्ट वन
लेकर आ रहे हैं जो 5 1/2 घंटे के आसपास
होगी। पार्ट टू भी आएगी। फिर लगभग 15 घंटे
की हम इसको बनाने की कोशिश कर रहे हैं आप
सबके लिए।
बहुत सारे कोर्सर्सेस भी नहीं होते हैं।
वैसे तो जो बिल्कुल बिगिनर फ्रेंडली होने
वाला है। एथिकल हैकिंग की कोर्स होने वाली
है। एंड जिनके पास कोई पैसा कोई अमाउंट
नहीं होता है किसी भी तरीके के कोर्स को
परचेस करने के लिए ₹500 भी नहीं होते। 200
भी नहीं होते। मान के चलता हूं मैं ऐसा कि
₹5000 भी बहुत मुश्किल कई लोगों के लिए हो
सकते हैं या नहीं होते हैं। या दे कैन नॉट
स्पेंड ऑन राइट? या दे कैन नॉट आस्क। तो
उनके लिए यह कोर्स वन शॉट वीडियो होने
वाली है। तो यह वीडियो बाकी वीडियोस
YouTube पे बहुत सारे ऐसे वन शॉट वीडियो
आपको मिलेंगे एथिकल हैकिंग के। बट वह बस
होते हैं क्योंकि व्यूज और यह सब भी चाहिए
होता है। बट यहां हमने उनसे बिल्कुल अलग
किया है यह कि हम आपको WhatsApp ग्रुप का
सपोर्ट प्रोवाइड करेंगे इस वन शॉट वीडियो
के साथ और वो सपोर्ट बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ
कॉस्ट होगा। यानी कि आपको कोई डाउट, कोई
परेशानी, कोई क्वेश्चन आई तो आप उस ग्रुप
में डिस्कस कर सकते हैं। आपके मेंटोर उस
ग्रुप में रहेंगे तो आप उनसे डायरेक्टली
कोई क्वेश्चन पूछ सकते हैं। वो आपके
रिप्लाई रिसोंड आपको रिस्पांस देंगे। एंड
व्हाटएवर क्वेरीज विल बी देयर दे विल
ट्राई टू सॉल्व। आप आपस में भी क्वेरी
सॉल्व कर सकते हैं सब कुछ। मतलब ओवरऑल इट
विल बी अ ग्रेट एक्सपीरियंस फॉर यू गाइस।
ठीक है? तो यह देख लीजिएगा। और कोर्स जो
है कल लाइव होने वाली है। कल आने वाली है।
अपलोड हो जाएगी कल शाम को 6:00 बजे तक
शायद। हां सैटरडे तो उस कोर्स को जरूर
देखिएगा। दोस्तों के बीच शेयर कीजिएगा।
जितना हो सके हाइप कर दीजिएगा उस वीडियो
को। हाइप आप लोग पता नहीं करते हैं कि
नहीं करते हैं। बट हाइप किया कीजिएगा।
जैसे ये वीडियो होती है। वीडियो जब आप ओपन
करते हैं राइट? आई थिंक मोबाइल डिवाइस पे
हाइप का ऑप्शन आता है। यहां शायद नहीं
आएगा।
या यहां पे ऑप्शन नहीं है। मोबाइल पे आपको
नीचे में हाइप का एक बटन आता है। तो
वीडियोस को हाइप किया कीजिएगा। चाहे वो
आपका लाइव का है, वीडियोस हो, कोई सा भी
हो। इसे YouTube जो है उन वीडियोस को आगे
दिखाता है, सजेस्ट करता है। एल्गोरििदम
ऐसे ही काम करता है YouTube का हाइप को
लेकर। राइट?
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
नाउ हियर [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] किसी
भी एसओसी के क्लास कोई से भी एसओसी का
क्लास जो है उसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको
चले जाना है सबसे पहले। एंड यहां पे दो
लिंक्स मिलेंगे। एक WhatsApp चैनल का, एक
WhatsApp ग्रुप का। WhatsApp चैनल पे
जितनी भी अपडेट्स होती है हमारे से, हमारे
हमारे तरफ से, हमारे साइड से जो भी
अपडेट्स होती हैं किसी भी तरह की वो सबसे
पहले WhatsApp चैनल पे ही आता है और कहीं
भी नहीं आता। तो आप इससे अपडेटेड रहेंगे
तो प्लीज इसको फॉलो जरूर कर लीजिएगा। आप
WhatsApp के ऊपर भी जाके एक्सप्लोर चैनल्स
पे जाके डेफ्रोनिक सर्च के भी फॉलो कर
सकते हैं। एक WhatsApp ग्रुप है जो कि
एसओसी एनालिस्ट्स के लिए स्पेसिफिक ग्रुप
है। इसी सीरीज के लिए जहां हम आपको
रिसोर्सेज एंड जो भी अपडेट्स हैं सीरीज के
वो प्रोवाइड करते हैं। नोट्स वगैरह सब कुछ
वहीं पे आपको मिलता है। साथ में अपकमिंग
जो भी अपडेट्स आएंगी रिगार्डिंग
सर्टिफिकेशन या व्हाटएवर इंटरव्यूज एंड ऑल
वो सब आपको इसी में मिलेगी। तो इसको भी
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। यह Lindin प्रोफाइल है।
आप मुझसे कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं यहां पे अ
पर्सनली एंड यू कैन डिस्कस एनीथिंग और यू
कैन लाइक कनेक्ट एंड यू कैन मैसेज मी ऑन
दिस पर्टिकुलर प्लेटफार्म Lindin यहीं पे
आप सर्च करेंगे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स तो आपको हमारा
डिफ़्रोनिक्स का भी Lindin पेज मिल जाता
है। जहां पे हम लाइक हमारी कंपनी की तरफ
से जो भी अपडेट्स हैं, जो भी वर्क अपडेट्स
हैं, जो भी चीजें हैं या कोई गिव अवे
अनाउंसमेंट्स होता है या व्हाटएवर कुछ
चीजें आती हैं, तो वह आपको यहां पे जो है
इसी पेज पे मिल जाएगी। तो इसको भी मेक
श्योर कि आप फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। डेफिनेटली
कर लीजिएगा। ठीक है? यहां पे मैंने ये चीज
जो है आपको आपको दिखा होगा बेसिकली कि वी
आर ब्रिंगिंग दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग। राइट?
यह [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] है
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी Instagram पेज जहां
आपको इनेशनल रील्स, कंटेंट्स यह सब मिल
जाएंगे रिगार्डिंग साइबर सिक्योरिटी। तो
डू फॉलो दिस पेज आल्सो। यह हमारा एक्स का
पेज है। प्लीज इसको भी फॉलो कर लीजिएगा।
साथ ही में यह हमारी वेबसाइट है। आप इस पे
हमारी सर्विज, हमारी चीजें एक्सप्लोर कर
सकते हैं। दिस इज गोइंग टू बी कंप्लीटली
रीड। तो, उसके बाद आपको बिल्कुल नया लुक
मिलेगा। एंड यह हमारा WhatsApp नंबर है।
आप इस पे हमसे किसी भी तरह की क्वेरी,
क्वेश्चन या कुछ भी मन में सवाल हो, यू
कैन आस्क हियर। यह मेरा पर्सनल Instagram
का पेज है। मेरी खुद की प्रोफाइल है। आप
चाहे तो इस पे आके मुझसे कनेक्ट हो सकते
हैं, फॉलो कर सकते हैं। राइट? ओके। सो
लेट्स बिगिन द जर्नी नाउ ऑफ टुडेेस सेशन द
क्लास नंबर 32 ऑफ एसओसी। अब यहां पे आज हम
फिशिंग एनालिसिस टूल्स के बारे में थोड़ा
पढ़ने वाले हैं। एंड यहां पे हम ट्राईकमी
का एक प्रीमियम रूम है जो कि कई सारे ऐसे
लर्नर्स हैं जिनके पास प्रीमियम रूम नहीं
होते हैं। वो सॉल्व नहीं कर पाते हैं और
वो परचेस भी नहीं शायद कर पाते हैं। उनके
लिए काफी इंपॉर्टेंट होगा यह। एंड इसमें
मैंने प्रीमियम रूम को इसको सेलेक्ट इसलिए
किया है क्योंकि यहां जो चीजें आपको मिल
रही हैं, रिसोर्सेज मिल रहा है वो इतना
स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे में शायद शायद इस टॉपिक
के लिए कहीं और जल्दी ना मिले आपको और
नई-नई चीजें इसके अंदर हैं। कुछ टूल्स
आपको देखने को मिलेगा। कुछ हैंड्स ऑन हम
करेंगे लैब्स के थ्रू। मजा आएगा। कुछ
चीजें सर्च करेंगे। कुछ पैकेट्स वगैरह के
ऊपर भी काम करेंगे। बहुत सारा चीज़ है जो
आज हम करने वाले हैं। तो इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट
टू एवरीबॉडी प्लीज फोकस ऑन द ट्रेनिंग
टुडे। एंड बहुत कुछ सीख कर आप जाओगे। ठीक
है? आज की क्योंकि फिशिंग कंप्लीशन होने
वाला है और ये एक बहुत बड़ा टॉपिक था।
इसलिए इस टॉपिक के दो क्लासेस हो गए हैं।
मतलब एक पहले हुआ था और एक ये वाला हो
गया। इसके बाद जो टॉपिक्स है वो उतने बड़े
टॉपिक्स नहीं है और ज्यादा टॉपिक्स बचे भी
नहीं है। तो आपका एसओसी भी जो है वो
कंप्लीशन की तरफ ही बढ़ रहा है। फिशिंग के
साथ-साथ मान के चलिए कि 80% सिलेबस विल बी
कंप्लीटेड। बस 20% रह जाएगा एंड दैट वुड
आल्सो बी कंप्लीट सून। हो जाएगा वो भी।
ठीक है? चलिए। सो
आज की भी हां अगेन आज की भी कोई स्लाइड
नहीं है क्योंकि उसकी जरूरत नहीं थी। टाइम
वेस्ट करने से कोई फायदा नहीं था क्योंकि
जहां स्लाइड की जरूरत होती है मैं वहां पे
स्लाइड आपको प्रोवाइड कर देता हूं। ठीक
है? चलिए। सो प्लीज फोकस एवरीबॉडी। ठीक
है?
चलिए अब यहां पर आ रहा है यह तो चलो इनका
जो भी है ऑब्जेक्टिव इंट्रोडक्शन है इनको
हटा देते हैं यहां कंटिन्यू चेक करके
कंटिन्यू हटा देते हैं
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आइडेंटिफाइंग
आर्टिफेक्ट्स इस पे काम करते हैं पहले
आइडेंटिफाइंग आर्टिफेक्ट्स क्या है देखो
व्हेन एनालाइजिंग अ सस्िशियस फ्रॉम
मलेशियस ईमेल देखिए मैं आपको ये चीजें
यहां भी लिखी हुई है राइट बट मैं आपको
चीजें इसलिए बता रहा हूं ताकि आपको बहुत
ही ज्यादा क्ल क्लेरिटी मिले। बहुत ही
ज्यादा क्लेरिटी के साथ आपको समझ में आए।
एक्सैक्टली कि एग्जैक्टली ये क्या है। मैं
आपको एक्सप्लेन करता चलूंगा तो आपको बहुत
क्लियर होता चलेगा। ठीक है? योर फर्स्ट
गोल इज टू कलेक्ट द आर्टिफेक्ट्स की
आर्टिफेक्ट्स दैट कैन हेल्प डिटरमाइन इट्स
लेजिटसी एंड इंटेंट। ठीक है? दीज़
आर्टिफेक्ट्स प्रोवाइड द फाउंडेशन फॉर
डीपर इन्वेस्टिगेशन सच एज रेपुटेशन चेक,
थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस लुक अप्स एंड बिहेवियरल
एनालिसिस। तो सबसे पहले क्या है कि आपको
जब भी आप ऐसी एनालिसिस करते हैं ठीक है कि
ये आर्टिफेक्ट्स आपको कलेक्ट करने हैं।
आपको आर्टिफेक्ट्स का मतलब है आपको कुछ
इंफॉर्मेशनेशंस कलेक्ट करने हैं। उन
इंफॉर्मेशनेशंस के बेसिस पे आप एग्जैक्ट
आप पता कर पाएंगे कि यह एक लेजिटमेट
इंफॉर्मेशन थी या फिर कोई मलेशियस केस है।
आपको पता चल जाएगा। तो, सबसे पहले
आर्टिफेक्ट्स में यहां पे हम बात करेंगे
हेडर आर्टिफेक्ट्स की एंड देन हम बॉडी
एनालिसिस की बात करेंगे। हेडर
आर्टिफेक्ट्स का मतलब क्या है? जो भी जैसे
कोई ईमेल आती है, राइट? कोई भी ईमेल हमारे
पास आती है, तो ईमेल के जो हेडर होते हैं,
हम उनके बारे में पहले एक डिटेल में थोड़ा
देखेंगे। व्हेन यू बिगिन योर एनालिसिस विथ
द ईमेल हेडर, यू शुड टेक नोट ऑफ़ द फॉलोइंग
पॉइंट्स। इन पॉइंट्स का आपको ध्यान रखना
है। जब भी कोई फिशिंग ईमेल या फिशिंग टाइप
मेल आएगी आपके पास तो इन जो
पॉइंट्स हैं इनका आपको ध्यान रखना है।
सबसे पहले आता है सेंडर ईमेल एड्रेस कि
सेंडर का ईमेल एड्रेस एग्जैक्टली है क्या?
आपको पूरा देखना है। आंखें बंद नहीं रखनी
है। ऊपर ऊपर का ऐसे नहीं देखना है। राइट?
बस देखना है अच्छे से। ठीक है? सेंडर IP
एड्रेस। व्हाट इज़ द सोर्स आईपी? सोर्स
आईपी क्या है? कहां से वह जो चीजें हैं
ओरिजनेट हुई है? उसका आईपी एड्रेस क्या
है? ईमेल का सब्जेक्ट लाइन क्या है? क्या
इसमें कोई अर्जेंसी है? कोई कॉल टू एक्शन
है? कुछ है ऐसा यह आपको देखना है।
रिसिपिएंट ईमेल एड्रेस कौन सा जो है वो
उसका रिसिपिएंट है। मतलब कौन किसको यह मेल
जा रहा है। किसको यह मेल डिलीवर हो रहा
है। यह आपको देखना है। रिप्लाई टू ईमेल
एड्रेस कि वेयर आर रिस्पांस बीइंग
डायरेक्टेड जैसे आप कोई रिस्प आप उस ईमेल
का रिसोंड करते हो तो वो रिस्पांस जो है
वो एग्जैक्टली कहां जा रहा है वेयर इट इज़
गोइंग ठीक है ये आपको देखना है डेट एंड
टाइम कब जो है ये ईमेल मतलब इसका डेट क्या
था टाइम क्या था ये आपको मेंशन मतलब ध्यान
देना है इस पे डेट एंड टाइम
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब आते हैं
बॉडी एनालिसिस पे व्हेन नेक्स्ट कम्स अ
ईमेल बॉडी व्हिच हैज़ इट्स ओन सेट ऑफ़
आर्टिफेक्ट्स बॉडी में में क्या होता है?
यूआरएल एंड हाइपरलिंक्स। बॉडी में आपको
देखना है कि भाई यूआरएल्स और हाइपरलिंक्स
यानी जो हैं उस पे थोड़ा ध्यान देना है कि
कहीं कोई मलिश यूआरएल तो नहीं है।
अटैचमेंट्स का नाम क्या है? ऐसा तो नहीं
कि कोई ऐसा अटैचमेंट या कुछ ऐसा एक्सटेंशन
है उस अटैचमेंट के अंदर जो सस्िशियस होते
हैं जो ऑलरेडी ऐसे नोन मैलवेयर्स के लिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] काफी पॉपुलर
होते हैं। अटैचमेंट्स हैश आपको उस
अटैचमेंट का एक हैश जनरेट करना है। थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस करनी है और आपको देखना है कि
ये क्या ये जो हैश वैल्यू है ये किसी तरह
का कोई मलशियस हैश वैल्यू तो नहीं है जो
ऑलरेडी ऐसे थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस प्लेटफॉर्म्स
के डेटाबेसिस में स्ट होते हैं। तो थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस प्लेटफार्म जो भी हैं जैसे मान
लो वायरस टोटल भी है जो काफी लोग यूज करते
हैं। ठीक है? एनी रन वगैरह भी यूज करते
हैं। तो उनके पास एक अपना डेटाबेस होता है
सारे मलेशियस फाइल्स का या मतलब
एक्सटेंशंस का, हैशेस का एंड डिफरेंट
काइंड ऑफ़ लिंक्स एंड ऑल सब कुछ। तो वो
अपने डेटाबेस मैच करके बताते हैं। तो आपको
देखना है कि एक्सैक्टली ये मैचिंग है कि
नहीं। [अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? तो यहां पे चेक कर लेते हैं।
इसमें कुछ है नहीं। इसमें कुछ अह क्वेश्चन
ही नहीं है। अब आते हैं ईमेल हेडर
एनालिसिस पे। अब इसमें आप मेन चीज है जो
आपको ध्यान देना है। देखो
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] इन फिशिंग
एनालिसिस अ क्या होता है कि जब भी इस सच
एज द सेंडर्स आईपी एड्रेस एंड रिप्लाई टू
इनेशन कैन ओनली बी ऑब्टेंड फ्रॉम द ईमेल
हेडर। जब आप एनालिसिस करेंगे तो ईमेल हेडर
से ही ये सेंडर की आईपी एड्रेस और रिप्लाई
टू जो इनेशन होती है वो आपको मिलती है।
ठीक है? तो मेल हेडर एनालिसिस की अगर बात
करें तो यहां पे देखो मैसेज हेडर पार्ट ऑफ
द Google एडमिन टूलबॉक्स ये एक टूल है।
मैसेज यहां पे मैं ओपन कर लेता हूं इसको
मैसेज हेडर। ठीक है? ये Google टूलबॉक्स
का जो है एक तरह का टूल है या Google
एडमिन टूलबॉक्स बोल लो मैसेज हेडर नाम से
जिसको यूज़ में लिया जाता है ईमेल हेडर्स
को एनालाइज करने के लिए। ठीक है? तो इन
टूल्स का यूज आप ईमेल हेडर एनालिसिस में
कर सकते हैं। बेसिकली पूरी की पूरी ईमेल
हेडर को यहां पे आप पेस्ट कर दीजिए और
उसके बाद ये एनालाइज करके ये पूरी डिटेल
जो है वो बताता है एग्जैक्टली उस हेडर के
बारे में। जैसे यहां पे ये एनालिसिस दी
हुई है। ठीक है? बाय सिंपली पेस्टिंग द
फुल हेडर इंटू द टूल यू कैन क्विकली
एक्सट्रैक्ट की डिटेल्स सच एज द सेंडर्स
IPपी एड्रेस जो सेंडर्स का IPपी एड्रेस
है। ठीक है?
राउटिंग पाथ, पोटेंशियल मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस
यह सारी चीजें इसमें आती है। ठीक है? यह
सारी चीजें इसमें आती है। तो ये आपको
डिटेल पता जैसे इन्होंने ईमेल हेडर डाला
होगा कोई तो ये डिटेल्स यहां पे आपको दिख
रही होगी। मैसेज आईडी क्रिएटेड एट फ्रॉम
टू सब्जेक्ट एसपीएफ, डीके आईएम ये सारी
फील्ड्स होती हैं। राइट? अनदर ग्रेट टूल
इज़ मैसेज हेडर एनालिसिस जो कि एक और टूल
है मैसेज हेडर एनालिसिस करके जो कि एमए
Azure वेबसाइट नेट एज योर Microsoft की
तरफ से आपको मिल जाता है। ये Google के
तरफ से ये Microsoft की तरफ से आपको मिल
जाता है। यहां भी आप हेडर पेस्ट करेंगे और
ये एनालिसिस करके आपको प्रॉपर जो है
डिटेल्स प्रोवाइड कर देता है। ठीक है? तो
ये हेडर एनालिसिस हो गया। अब यहां पे हेडर
में सब कुछ होता है। लाइक मैसेज जो है
किसको मैं मतलब उसका आईडी क्या है? कब
क्रिएट हुई थी? कहां से भेजा गया है?
किसको भेजा गया? सब्जेक्ट क्या है? एसपीएफ
सेंटर पॉलिसी फ्रेमवर्क जो होता है वो
क्या है? ये भी इस पे भी हम बात करेंगे कि
एसपीएफ वगैरह क्या होता है? ये सब भी हम
बात करेंगे। डीके आईएम ये सब भी हम बात
करेंगे। ये सब भी हम पढ़ेंगे। ठीक है? तो
उसके लिए बेफिक्र रहिएगा अभी। IP एंड
यूआरएल रेपुटेशन एनालिसिस। उसके बाद आती
है जब आप मैसेज हेडर का एनालिसिस करते हैं
तो अब आईपी और यूआरएल के रेपुटेशन का
एनालिसिस करना है कि भैया ये जो IPपी
एड्रेस है ये जो यूआरएल है इसका रेपुटेशन
लेवल क्या है? मतलब रेपुटेशन का मतलब है
किस रेपुटेशन को होल्ड करते हैं। जैसे अब
आपकी क्या रेपुटेशन है? राइट? आप किस लेवल
की रेपुटेशन को होल्ड करते हैं? अगर आपकी
रेपुटेशन अच्छी है मतलब आप अच्छे इंसान
हैं। रेपुटेशन खराब है मतलब आप खराब इंसान
हैं। उसी तरीके से आईपी की रेपुटेशन अच्छी
है तो मतलब ये एक हेल्दी आईपी हो सकती है।
यूआरएल की रेपुटेशन अगर अच्छी है तो
यूआरएल एक हेल्दी यूआरएल या नॉन मलेशियस
यूआरएल हो सकता है। रेपुटेशन खराब है तो
वो जो यूआरएल है जो IP एड्रेस है वो
मलशियस कैटेगरी का हो सकता है। ये
इन्वेस्टिगेट करना है। इसके लिए एक
वेबसाइट है IP info करके। यह जो टूल है IP
info.iio. ठीक है? दिस टूल कैन बी यूज्ड
टू अ बेसिकली एनालाइज द मतलब द यूआरएल्स
एंड द आईपी एड्रेसेस इनके रेपुटेशन को आप
IP इनफो पे एनालिसिस जो है आप कर सकते
हैं। दिस इज़ अ वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल दैट
कैन बी यूज़्ड। राइट? चलिए अभी हम इसको
देखेंगे। अभी आओ।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] IP
इनफो इज अ सिंपल एंड इफेक्टिव टूल फॉर
गैदरिंग इनफेशन अबाउट एन आईपी एड्रेस। बाय
भाई देखो ऐसे तो बहुत सारी
मतलब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
वेबसाइट्स हैं जिसको आप यूज़ कर सकते हैं।
बट ये भी काफी अच्छी है। बाय एंटरिंग एन
आईपी यू कैन क्विकली व्यू डिटेल्स सच
ऐग्राफिक लोकेशन एंड एसोसिएटेड
ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस। दिस हेल्प्स एनालिस्ट
डिटरमाइन वेदर एन आईपी इज़ पोटेंशियली
मलेशियस। तो अब IP इनफो वैसे भी आप सर्च
करेंगे ना आईपी इनफेशन IP इनफेशन तो आपको
वैसे बहुत सारी वेबसाइट्स वैसे भी मिल
जाएगी इंटर आईपी इनफो का ये सब ये सब जो
वेबसाइट्स हैं आपकी ये सारी वेबसाइट भी है
जैसे आप आईपी डालो उनकी यहां पे डिटेल जो
है काफी डिटेल आपको यहां पे मिल जाती है
तो कुछ इसी तरीके से हमारा इस वाले में भी
आईपी डालोगे आईपी की डिटेल जो है आपको मिल
जाएगी ये तो मैंने आपको बता ही दिया तो ये
आईपी इनेशन जो है वो निकालने के वेबसाइट्स
है अब एक वेबसाइट है url scan.io दिस इज़ द
वेबसाइट url scan.io यहां पे आप यूआरएल्स
को टेस्ट कर सकते हैं। यू कैन स्कैन द
यूआरएल सैंडbox यूआर sandbox एनवायरमेंट
में आप यूआरएल्स को स्कैन कीजिए। उसके
बारे में पूरी जो है डिटेल आपको पता चल
जाएगी। जैसे यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
रीसेंट में लोगों ने स्कैन किया है।
अलग-अलग यूआरएल्स को आप देख सकते हैं यहां
पे। जैसे कोई सी भी यूआरएल है। जैसे मान
लो ये एक यूआरएल है। इसको किसी ने स्कैन
किया है। राइट? तो आप ये देख सकते हैं
सारी स्कैन रिपोर्ट आपको यहां पे मिल
जाएगी। वन मंथ ओल्ड का है। पब्लिक स्कैन
हुई है। पब्लिक स्कैन हुई है। नॉर्मल से
स्कैन हुई है। यहां पे टेक्नोलॉजीस वगैरह
इस पे क्या है वो डिटेक्ट हुई है। डोमेनस
आईपी इनफेशन सारी हो गई है। ठीक है? यहां
पे वर्डिक्ट है। यहां पे वर्डिक्ट आती है
कि नो क्लासिफिकेशन। कोई ऐसा कोई
क्लासिफिकेशन इसका है नहीं। कुछ वैसा ओके
है तो ये मतलब सारी चीजें आपको हो सकता है
इसमें कुछ जैसे ये मैं यूआरएल देता हूं
donate directly.com तो मैंने donate
directly.com यहां पे ओपन किया तो इसमें
भी लाइक सारी डिटेल्स और जो भी चीजें हैं
वो सारी चीजें आपको यहां पे आती है। यह
स्क्रीनशॉट आपको दे देते हैं। कुछ इस
तरीके का दिखता है कि बाय चांस आपको देखना
हो उसका एक वो करना है तो आपको यहां पे
देखने को मिल जाएगा। राइट? यहां पे
स्टैटिक्स उस वेबसाइट से रिलेटेड क्या
स्टैटिक्स है उस वेबसाइट की अ उसके लाइक
डोमेनस वगैरह क्या सब कुछ आपको डिटेल में
आपको ये यूआरएल स्कैनिंग जो है यूआरएल आप
स्कैन बेसिकली कर सकते हैं। तो टूल दैट
इनेबल्स एनालिस्ट टू सेफली इन्वेस्टिगेट
वेबसाइट्स विदाउट विजिटिंग देम
डायरेक्टली। मतलब बिना डायरेक्टली विजिट
किया आप वेब अह यूआरएल्स को स्कैन कर सकते
हैं। बाय सबमिटिंग द यूआरएल द सर्विस
सिमुलेट्स अ रियल यूजर ब्राउजिंग सेशन एंड
रिकॉर्ड्स ऑल एक्टिविटी जनरेटेड बाय द
पेज। तो एक रियल ब्राउजिंग सेशन को
सेमुलेट करता है और जितने भी ब्राउजिंग
लाइक जितने भी एक्टिविटी है उस उस पेज के
वो सब जनरेट कर देता है। ये स्क्रीनशॉट भी
कैप्चर करता है और सारी डिटेल्स आपको
प्रोवाइड करता है। अब टैल की जो है आईपीए
डोमेन रेपुटेशन सेंटर ये एक और टूल है।
देखो टूल्स बहुत सारे आज आपको पता चलने
वाले हैं। मजा आएगा आपको इसलिए मैंने बोला
था काफी इंटरेस्टिंग क्लास होने वाली है
आपके लिए आज की। ठीक है?
अ हां वाश शार्क होगा हम करेंगे कवर वाय
शार्क विल बी कवरिंग शौर्य दत्ता वाय
शार्क का हमारा अभी क्लास जो है वो होगा
आपको डिटेल में मैं वो क्लास कराऊंगा उसके
लिए बेफिक्रिए आईएसओ की कुछ खास नॉलेज की
जरूरत नहीं है बट वशार्क इज़ेंट सो आईपीए
डोमेन रेपुटेशन सेंटर है यहां पे अ लाइक
टैलस की तरफ से आता है सिस्को टैलॉस जो है
उनके तरफ से यह एक थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
प्लेटफार्म है सो बेसिकली यहां पे आप IP,
यूआरएल, डोमेन, नेटवर्क ओनर, फाइल लाइक
कुछ भी आप यहां पे डालेंगे एंड आप उसके
बारे में पूरी डिटेल इन्वेस्टिगेशन जो है
वो कर सकते हैं। कंप्लीट डिटेल
इन्वेस्टिगेशन यू कैन डू। सो थ्रू टेलस
आईपी एंड डोमेन इज़ अ थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस टूल
फ्रॉम Sisco दैट इनेबल्स एनालिस्ट्स टू
एक्सेस द रेपेटेशन ऑफ़ IPपी एड्रेसेस,
डोमेनस, नेटवर्क्स। तो, आप IPपी एड्रेसेस,
डोमेनस, नेटवर्क सबके रेपेटेशन चेक कर
सकते हैं इस पे आके। बाय सबमिटिंग एन
इंडिकेटर यू कैन क्विकली असेस वेदर इट हैज़
बीन एसोसिएटेड विथ मेलिसिस एक्टिविटी एंड
व्यू इट्स क्लासिफिकेशन। तो कोई सा भी आप
यहां पे इंडिकेटर डाल दीजिए। कुछ भी डाल
दीजिए। जैसे आईपी एड्रेस डाल यूआरएल डाल
दीजिए, डोमेन डाल दीजिए और यह बताएगा कि
एग्जैक्टली ये जो यूआरएल है या डोमेन है
या व्हाटएवर नेटवर्क है ये किसी मलशियस
एक्टिविटी से इसका कोई लेना देना है या
नहीं था। अभी था रिसेंट में कुछ है या कुछ
नहीं। वो सब आपको यहां पे डिटेल में
बताएगा। जैसे कि यहां पे आपको दिख रहा
होगा इन्होंने जैसे एक IP एड्रेस डली हुई
है तो उसकी पूरी यहां पे डिटेल जो है आपको
यहां मिल जाएगी। जैसे ओनर की क्या डिटेल
है? ईमेल जो होती है इसके मतलब उस आईपी का
यूज़ करके वॉल्यूम उसका वॉल्यूम क्या है?
ठीक है? तो सेंडर आईपी रेपुटेशन क्या है?
न्यूट्रल है। मतलब नॉर्मल आईपी रेपुटेशन
है। ठीक है। कोई मशियस टाइप का कुछ खास
नहीं है। तो ये यहां से एग्जैक्टली इस
टैलॉस जो है डोमेन आईपी रेपुटेशन सेंटर
यहां आप देख सकते हैं। ठीक है? आई होप कि
ये आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। अकॉर्डिंग टू
द मैसेज हेडर एनालिसिस शोन इन दिस टास्क
व्हाट इज द एसपीएफ रिजल्ट फॉर द ईमेल। अब
यहां पे मैसेज हेडर एनालिसिस जो है इसमें
एसपीएफ रिजल्ट क्या है? तो आप देख सकते
हैं ऊपर में हमने मैसेज हेडर एनालिसिस
किया था ये वाला मैसेज मेल हेडर एनालिसिस।
इसमें आपको एसपीएफ का रिजल्ट जो है ये
आपको दिख रहा होगा एसपीएफ का रिजल्ट यहां
पे पास है। मतलब एसपीएफ रिजल्ट पास है।
मतलब यहां पे एसपीएफ का रिकॉर्ड है। एंड
इट्स ओके फाइन। एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड अवेलेबल
है। एसपीएफ का मतलब होता है सेंडर्स
पॉलिसी फ्रेमवर्क। ठीक है?
सेंडर्स पॉलिसी फ्रेमवर्क। इसका मतलब यह
है कि एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड अगर किसी डोमेन का
प्रेजेंट होता है तो उस केस में उस
डोमेन के
ईमेल्स जो होते हैं ईमेल आईडीस जो डोमेन
ईमेल होते हैं उसका यूज़ कोई थर्ड पार्टी
करके उससे मेल सेंड नहीं कर सकता। अगर
एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड नहीं है तो यह चांसेस बढ़
जाते। तो यहां रिजल्ट जो है पास है। हम
एसपीएफ को भी थोड़ा जानेंगे। तो यहां पे
मेरा आंसर हो जाएगा पास।
ठीक है? चलिए यहां तक हमने कर लिया। हम
आगे भी अभी बढ़ेंगे। बस मुझे पहले अभी बता
दीजिए सभी लोग कि प्लीज इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट
टू एवरीबॉडी कि यहां तक अभी आपको सब कुछ
समझ में आ रहा है आप लोगों को? एवरीथिंग
इज क्लियर?
प्लीज लेट मी नो।
सभी लोग बताइए क्लियर है यहां तक
इफ एवरीथिंग इज क्लियर लेट मी नो
कोई बात नहीं है गौरव लेट आए बट आए तो सही
हेयर बैंड लगा के पुखी लग रहे हैं। पुखी
क्या होता है भाई?
व्हाट इज व्हाट इज व्हाट इज पुकी? मुझे
नहीं पता।
चलो ठीक है
सर कैन यू चेक वेब सिक्योरिटी
नहीं भाई
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है ठीक है ओके थैंक यू
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] चलिए
तो लेट्स स्टार्ट अगेन आगे की तरफ हम बढ़ते
हैं ठीक है अब आ जाते हैं ईमेल बॉडी
एनालिसिस के ऊपर में ठीक है ईमेल बॉडी
एनालिसिस में यहां पे हम मेल बॉडी जो होती
है जो मेल एग्जैक्ट कंटेंट होता है मेल का
जिसमें चीजें लिखी हुई होती है राइट मैसेज
लिखा होता है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सॉरी
उसको हम यहां पे एनालिसिस करेंगे। ठीक है?
मेल बॉडी एनालिसिस में डिटरमाइनिंग द
डेस्टिनेशन ऑफ अ लिंक विद इन एन ईमेल कैन
बी एज इजी एज राइट क्लिकिंग द लिंक एंड
सेलेक्टिंग कॉपी लिंक एड्रेस। ठीक है?
फ्रॉम हियर यू कैन सेफली एक्सेस द यूआरएल
विदाउट एक्चुअली फॉलोइंग इट टू द
डेस्टिनेशन। सिंपल। तो अब यहां पे क्या है
कि मेल बैडी एनालिसिस जब आप मेल बॉडी की
एनालिसिस करते हैं तो होता क्या है कि जब
जैसे कोई मान लो कि कोई बटन दिया है मेल
के बॉडी में कोई बटन है। राइट? उस पे कोई
लिंक डली हुई है। तो आप क्या कर सकते हैं?
राइट क्लिक किया उसमें। कॉपी लिंक एड्रेस
का ऑप्शन आता है। लिंक कॉपी किया और आपको
एग्जैक्ट लिंक जो है पता चल जाती है कि
आखिर इसका यूआरएल एग्जैक्ट है क्या?
मलिशियस यूआरएल है या जेन्युइन यूआरएल है।
अनदर इफेक्टिव वे टू आइडेंटिफाई यूआरएल्स
इन एन ईमेल इज़ टू यूज़ यूआरएल एक्सट्र
एक्सट्रैक्शन टूल। ये एक यूआरएल
एक्सट्रैक्शन टूल है। मैं बाकी इसको हटा
देता हूं।
यह एक यूआरएल एक्सट्रैक्शन टूल है। जहां
पे आप बेसिकली यूआरएल जो है आप
एक्सट्रैक्ट कर सकते हो। हो दीज़ टूल्स लेट
यू पेस्ट रॉ ईमेल कंटेंट। आप कोई सा भी रॉ
ईमेल कंटेंट डालिए एंड ऑटोमेटिकली पास ऑल
इंबेडेड लिंक्स और उसमें से वो जितने भी
लिंक्स हैं उसको निकाल लेगा। सेविंग टाइम
एंड रिड्यूसिंग द रिस्क ऑफ़ मिसिंग हिडन और
ऑफ फस्टकेटेड यूआरएल्स। ठीक है? तो मतलब
आप इसमें रॉ ईमेल डालिए। यहां पे सिंपल आप
इसमें लाइक कोई सा भी रॉ ईमेल डालिए। ठीक
है? और उसमें से आपको एक्सट्रैक्ट करना
है। यहां पे आउटपुट ऑप्शन आपको सेलेक्ट कर
सकते हैं। ये ऑप्शनल रहता है। इसको छोड़
दीजिए और एक्सट्रैक्ट यूआरएल कीजिएगा। तो
सारे जितने भी यूआरएल्स हैं वो यूआरएल जो
है एक्सट्रैक्ट करके आपको प्रोवाइड कर
देगा। जैसे कुछ इस तरीके से यहां पे
एग्जांपल दिखाया गया है कि यहां पे एक
यूआरएल रॉ ईमेल डाली गई है। कोई जो ईमेल
आपको रिसीव हुई है डाल दीजिए। एंड यहां पे
आपको इसके जो भी लिंक्स है वो आपको देखने
को मिल जाएंगे। टूल्स लाइक साइबर सेफ कैन
आल्सो परफॉर्म दिस फंक्शन मेकिंग देम अ
वर्सटाइल ऑप्शन फॉर ईमेल। साइबर सेफ जैसे
जो प्लेटफॉर्म्स हैं इस पे भी इस तरीके की
चीजें जो हैं वो यूआर यूआरएल्स
एक्सट्रैक्ट करने की की जाती है।
एक्सट्रैक्ट यूआरएल का रेसिपी यहां पे
अवेलेबल होता है। आप ऐसे भी सर्च कर सकते
हैं। [अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
एक्सट्रैक्ट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यूआरएल्स वाला एंड ये रेसिपी के थ्रू आप
यहां पे इनपुट डालिए ईमेल और एक्सट्रैक्ट
कर दिया जाएगा। ठीक है? इस तरीके से होती
है। अब ईमेल अटैचमेंट्स की बात करें। ईमेल
में जो अटैचमेंट्स आते हैं। सो प्लीज इधर
फोकस कर लीजिए सभी लोग। ईमेल में जो भी
अटैचमेंट्स होते हैं। ठीक है? जो भी अब
फाइल्स डॉक्यूमेंट्स होती हैं उनकी बात अब
कर देते हैं। इफ द ईमेल यू आर
इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग कंटेंस एन अटैचमेंट। अगर
कोई जो ईमेल आप इन्वेस्टिगेट कर रहे हैं
उसमें अटैचमेंट है कोई। इट मे बी टेंपटिंग
टू डाउनलोड इट डायरेक्टली यूजिंग योर ईमेल
क्लाइंट। आप डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं। बहुत
टपटिंग कभी-कभी होता है कि अरे भाई
डाउनलोड करके देखते हैं क्या है। हो सकता
है आपको टेंपटिंग लगे। वो ऐसा दिखाया जाए
कि आप तुरंत उस फाइल को डाउनलोड कर ले
अपने सिस्टम पे। हाउएवर एन अटैचमेंट शुड
ओनली बी डाउनलोडेड इन अ कंट्रोलोल्ड
एनवायरमेंट? कभी भी ऐसी अटैचमेंट जहां पे
आपको बिल्कुल डाउट है 1% का भी ऐसे
अटैचमेंट्स को आपको एक कंट्रोलोल्ड सैंड
बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट में ही डाउनलोड और
एग्जीक्यूट करना चाहिए। सैंड बॉक्स का
मतलब एक सेपरेट एनवायरमेंट जो आपके सिस्टम
से सेपरेट हो। आपके सिस्टम पे इंपैक्ट ना
पड़े। उसका अगर किसी तरह का मलिशस
एक्टिविटी उस फाइल अटैचमेंट की तरफ से
होती है। वो आपके मेन सिस्टम को इफेक्ट
एटलीस्ट तो ना करे। सच एज लैब मशीनंस और
सैंड बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट टू रिड्यूस द रिस्क
ऑफ एक्सीडेंशियल एग्जीक्यूशन। वंस सेफली
ऑब्टेंड यू कैन यूज़ टूल्स लाइक एसए 256 सम
कमांड इन अ लinक्स एनवायरमेंट टू जनरेट अ
हैश वैल्यू फॉर द फॉर द एनालिसिस एंड
रेपिटेशन चेक। तो जब ऐसे अटैचमेंट होती है
तो आपको लinक्स में एक कमांड है एसए 256
सम। ठीक है? इससे बेसिकली क्या होता है कि
एसए 256#श जो है वह जनरेट हो जाती है इस
पर्टिकुलर फाइल की और आप जो है उस हैश को
एनालाइज़ करके पता लगा सकते हैं कि यह एक
मलिशियस फाइल है कि नहीं क्योंकि अटैचमेंट
देख के या डाउनलोड करके उसको कैसे पता
करोगे आप कि ये मलिशियस है कि नहीं है। एक
और चीज है कि अटैचमेंट को ही वायरसल या
एनी रन जैसे एप्लीकेशनेशंस पे अपलोड कर दो
और वहां से आप थोड़ी उसकी एनालिसिस कर लो
और आप हैश जनरेट करके भी ऐसे कर सकते हैं।
ठीक है? वंस यू हैव ऑब्टेंटेड द हैश
वैल्यू सेवरल साइट्स कैन सेफली असिस्ट विद
एनालाइजिंग द अटैच फाइल जैसे कि आईपी
डोमेन रेपुटेशन सेंटर जो है वो भी कर सकता
है वायरस टोटल जो है वो भी कर सकता है एंड
इरन जैसी वेबसाइट्स भी कर सकती है तो देयर
आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स दैट कैन बी यूज़्ड
मल्टीपल प्लेटफॉर्म्स ठीक है वायरस टोटल
जो है ये भी यूज़ में लिया जा सकता है जैसे
आपको मैंने बताया कि दिस इज़ आल्सो अ वन ऑफ़
द ग्रेट वेबसाइट यूज़्ड ऐज़ अ थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस प्लेटफार्म आल्सो थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस में काफी इसका यूज़ होता है
चाहे वह फाइल्स की एनालिसिस की बात करें
हम यूआरएल की एनालिसिस की बात करें या हम
IP एड्रेस डोमेन हैश जो वैल्यू है उनकी
बात करें या कुछ भी वो सब यहां पे आपको
देखने को मिल जाता है। सो दिस इज़ अ ग्रेट
वेबसाइट वायरस Tot तो आप यहां पे भी सारी
डिटेल्स चेक आउट कर सकते हैं। जैसे कोई आप
यहां पे देख सकते हैं पीडीएफ आपने अपलोड
कर दिया जो पीडीएफ है। तो ये अलग-अलग जो
वेंडर्स हैं सिक्योरिटी वेंडर्स यानी कि
जो जिनकी सिक्योरिटी टूल्स वगैरह आती हैं
वो वेंडर्स बताएंगे कि भैया ये सेफ है कि
अनसेफ है कि मलेशियस है कि वायरस है कोई
ट्रोजन है मैलवेयर है वार्म है क्या है इट
विल शो दैट यू अब यहां क्वेश्चन है सिंपल
व्हाट कमांड कैन यू यूज़ इन linx टू ऑब्टेन
द एसए 25 तो हमने अभी पढ़ा था कि इसका हम
सॉरी सॉरी हमने पढ़ा था इसका कमांड है एसए
256 सम है ना सम शायद
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एस यू 2 m
हां तो 256 ठीक है ओके हो गया अब आते हैं
मैलवेयर सैंड बॉक्सेस के लिए माल्वे सैंड
बॉक्सेस के लिए यानी कि स्पेशली माल्वेस
को एनालाइज करने के लिए एक बहुत ही अच्छी
यूआरएल बहुत ही अच्छी टूल है या
प्लेटफार्म है जिसको हम एनी रन बोलते हैं।
ठीक है? यह वेबसाइट है app.
रन दिस इज़ अ वेरी पॉपुलर वेरी वाइडली
यूज़्ड मैलवेयर एनालिसिस प्लेटफार्म।
बेसिकली यह वैसे तो मतलब वो भी देते हैं
इनका पेड प्लान्स वगैरह भी इनका आता है बट
आप ऐसे भी इसको वो कर सकते हैं। मतलब यूज़
कर सकते हैं जो कि कम्युनिटी एडिशन इनका
है और फिर इनका अलग-अलग हंटर एंटरप्राइज
शूट वगैरह ये सब आता है। राइट? तो आप जो
भी मतलब अभी फ्री में भी आप इसको आराम से
यूज़ कर सकते हैं। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है।
कम्युनिटी एडिशन इनका बिल्कुल ही फ्री
होता है। तो यहां पे आप सबमिट फाइल या
ईमेल आप डायरेक्ट ईमेल या फाइल सबमिट कर
सकते हैं एनी रन के ऊपर में। ठीक है? यहां
पे आप यूआरएल सबमिट कर सकते हैं।
सस्पिशियस लिंक्स जो है उसको आप चेक यहां
पे कर सकते हैं। तो ये सारी चीजें मतलब जो
है आप कर सकते हैं। और यहां पे पूरी डिटेल
इंटरेक्टिव मतलब पूरा आपको डिटेल यहां पे
मिल जाएगा। ठीक है? तो एनी रन इज़ एन
इंटैक्टिव मलवेयर सैंड बॉक्स दैट अलाउज़
एनालिस्ट्स टू सेफली एग्जीक्यूट एंड
ऑब्ज़र्व सस्िशियस फाइल्स एंड इवल्स इन द
रियल टाइम। रियल टाइम में सेफली जो है आप
एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं मैल्वेस को या
किसी भी तरह की सस्पिशियस फाइल्स को और आप
ऑब्ज़र्व कर सकते हैं। मतलब आप उसको जैसे
कोई पीडीएफ है मान लो कोई या कोई ऐसी फाइल
है जो आपको लग रहा हो डॉक डॉक फाइल है कोई
Microsoft का फाइल है या कोई पीडीएफ फाइल
है। ठीक है? या कोई जिप फाइल कुछ भी आपको
लग रहा है ये मैिसियस हो सकता है। आपको
डाउट है उस पे तो आप सिंपल सा फंडा है कि
आप उस फाइल को यहां पे अपलोड कर दीजिए। ये
रियल टाइम में उस फाइल को यहीं पे
एग्जीक्यूट कर देगा। यहीं पे चला देगा।
आपके लिए ओपन कर देगा और इसके बिहेवियर को
आप जो है ऑब्जर्व कर सकते हैं। अनलाइक
ट्रेडिशनल सैंड बॉक्सेस इट प्रोवाइड्स अ
हैंड्स ऑन एक्सपीरियंस इन व्हिच यू कैन
इंटैक्ट विथ द एनवायरमेंट मॉनिटर द
प्रोसेससेस व्यू नेटवर्क एक्टिविटी एंड
एनालाइज़ सिस्टम चेंजेस एज़ दे हैपन। इसका
मतलब सिंपल सा ये है कि ये एक छोटा सा
कंप्यूटर है अपने आप में। जैसे एक कोई
फाइल को आप डाउनलोड करते हैं। एक कोई फाइल
को आप इंस्टॉल करके ओपन कर लेते हैं या
डाउनलोड करके उसको एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं।
तो आपके सिस्टम में जिस तरीके से वो काम
कर रहा है। रियल सिस्टम मेरा जैसे ये
सिस्टम है। अब यहां मैंने कोई मालवेयर को
एग्जीक्यूट कर दिया। तो अब वो मलवेयर मेरे
सिस्टम पे जैसे-जैसे काम कर रहा है ना कोई
नई कोई डुप्लीकेट प्रोसेस बना रहा है किसी
प्रोसेस को मिमिक कर रहा है सिस्टम के
अंदर चेंजेस कर रहा है रजिस्ट्री में
चेंजेस कर रहा है शेड्यूल टास्क में
चेंजेस कर रहा है या पर्सिस्टेंस या मतलब
कुछ भी ट्राई कर रहा है मेरे सिस्टम के
अंदर में तो वो तो मेरे सिस्टम में पता चल
रहा है मैं देख मैं समझ रहा हूं कि हां ये
ये चीज हो रही है तो सेम चीजें नेटवर्क
एक्टिविटी में किस तरीके से वो उसकी
बिहेवियर आपको दिख रही है वो सब कुछ आप जो
है एनी रन के अंदर में एक वर्चुअल सैंड
बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट के अंदर देख सकते हैं
जिससे आपका सिस्टम भी इफेक्ट नहीं होगा और
आप एनालिसिस भी कर सकते हैं जो भी चीज़ है।
ठीक है? सेंट 100 थैंक यू वेरी मच
सौम्यजीत दास वेलकम वेलकम
सैंड बॉक्स है। सैंड बॉक्स है। ठीक है?
ओके। दिस मेक्स इट अ पावरफुल टूल फॉर
अंडरस्टैंडिंग हाउ मैलवेयर बिहेव्स एंड
आइडेंटिफाइंग कीज़ इंडिकेटर ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइजिंग इन। अब ये मलवेयर
एनालिसिस में इस टूल का यूज़ में लिया जाता
है। ठीक है? मैल्वे एनालिसिस अगर आप में
से कोई पढ़ा होगा या जानता होगा या पढ़ते
होंगे या पढ़ेंगे कभी तो ये टूल काफी
ज्यादा यूज़ होता है मेलवे एनालिसिस के
अंदर में। एंड
अ
फाइल्स या जो भी मेलिसिस हुआ है उसके बारे
में डिटेल में जानने के लिए। अब इसी तरीके
का एक टूल है हाइब्रिड एनालिसिस। अब ये
क्या है? एक फ्री मेल एनालिसिस टूल है।
सैंड बॉक्स टूल है। ये तो पेड वाला वर्जन
है। एनी रन इज़ अ पेड वर्जन। क्योंकि इसका
कम्युनिटी एडिशन तो फ्री है बट उसमें
लिमिटेशंस हैं और पेड वाले भी हैं। तो उसी
तरीके से एक आपका वो है अ कहां गया भाई?
हाइब्रिड एनालिसिस। ठीक है? तो ये आप यहां
पे फ्री में आप एनालिसिस कर सकते हैं।
मतलब फाइल या यूआरएल का हो गया या
डायरेक्ट यूआरएल ओनली या डायरेक्ट यूआरएल
जो फाइल तक का उसका डिटेल है। फाइल कशंस
है यहां पे रिपोर्ट रिसर्च है। बहुत सारी
चीजें कर सकते हैं। तो बेसिकली यू कैन यूज़
द हाइब्रिड एनालिसिस टूल आल्सो टू लाइक एन
एनालाइज़ द मैलवेयर्स एनालाइज़ द ओवरसा। तो
ऐसा जो टूल है इसको भी आप यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। इट प्रोवाइड डिटेल इनाइट्स इनू फाइल
बिहेवियर इंक्लूडिंग सिस्टम चेंजेस,
नेटवर्क एक्टिविटी, इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज, हेल्पिंग एनालिस्ट ये भी
आपको सारी डिटेल जैसे है वो भी आपको
प्रोवाइड करता है। ठीक है? ये भी आपका एक
सैंडbox एनवायरमेंट प्रोवाइड करता है। ठीक
है? अब देखिए यहां पे एक और आता है जोई
सैंड बॉक्स जोई सैंडbक्स अब जोई सैंडbक्स
क्रिएटेड द जोई सैंडbox मतलब एक जोई
सिक्योरिटी है जोई सिक्योरिटी ने सॉरी जोई
सिक्योरिटी ने जोई सैंड बॉक्स बनाया फॉर
एडवांस मैलवे एनालिसिस मैल फॉर एडवांस मैल
एनालिसिस के लिए इन्होंने बताया इट
परफॉर्म्स बोथ स्टैटिक एंड डायनेमिक
एनालिसिस अब मैल्वेयर्स एनालिसिस में आप
लोगों को आप लोगों में से कुछ लोगों को
शायद पता होगा एक सैस्ट होता है एक डस्ट
होता है कुछ ऐसे मतलब एक अह बेसिकली एक अह
लाइक स्टैटिक एनालिसिस होती है। एक
डायनेमिक एनालिसिस होती है। ठीक है? तो ये
दोनों टाइप के एनालिसिस कर सकता है। जो भी
सस्िशियस फाइल्स हैं, यूआरएल्स हैं सब पे।
राइट? सब पे ये कर सकता है। इट जनरेट्स
कंप्रहेंसिव रिपोर्ट्स दैट हाईलाइट
बिहेवियर इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ़ कॉम्प्रोमाइज एंड
थ्रेट क्लासिफिकेशन। एक बहुत डिटेल
रिपोर्ट जनरेट करता है जिसमें सारी
डिटेल्स वगैरह यहां पे होती है। तो यहां
पे जेई सैड बॉक्स क्लाउड बेसिक का यह आ
रहा है। इसको हटाओ। यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं।
कुछ इस तरीके से है। जैसे आपको आपका मशीन
चूज़ करना है। भाई किस टाइप के आर्किटेक्चर
के लिए आप यह एनालिसिस करना चाहते हैं।
Windows के लिए, Mac OS के लिए, Android
के लिए, Linux के लिए या कोई एडवांस मतलब
प्लेटफार्म कुछ है। तो यहां पे Windows के
लिए है। तो आप मान लो सैंपल फाइल को अपलोड
यहां पे कर दिया। या यूआरएल है कोई उस
फाइल का तो वहां आपने डाल दिया। एनालिसिस
सिस्टम यहां पे प्रोवाइड करते हैं। ये
अलग-अलग कि कौन सा Windows 10, Windows 11
में कौन सा वर्जन क्या आप यूज़ करना चाहते
हैं वो आप यूज़ कर लीजिए। व्हाटएवर यू
वांट्स टू यूज़ एंड देन जो है आप इसकी पूरी
एनालिसिस जो है एनालाइज़ करके इसके रिजल्ट
को देख सकते हैं। तो मैल एनालिसिस में ये
आपकी काफी हेल्प करेगा जो सैंड बॉक्स। ठीक
है? अंडरस्टैंड? ठीक है? इसमें भी कुछ भी
नहीं है। हटा दीजिए। अब इसके बाद एक टूल
आती है फिश टूल। फिश टूल। यह भी काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है। अ पावरफुल प्लेटफार्म
दैट स्ट्रीमलाइंस फिशिंग इन्वेस्टिगेशंस
इज़ फिश टूल। ये फिशिंग इन्वेस्टिगेशन को
बहुत ही स्ट्रीमलाइन प्रोसेस स्ट्रीमलाइन
कर देता है। इट इज़ डिज़ फॉर सिक्योरिटी
प्रोफेशनल्स अक्रॉस मल्टीपल डिसिप्लिंस।
ये स्पेशली सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल्स के लिए
जो है बनाया गया है। डेवलप किया गया है।
फिश टूल्स ऑटोमेट्स मच ऑफ द मैनुअल वर्क
इनवॉल्वड इन एनालिसिस एनालिस एनालाइजिंग
सस्िशियस ईमेल्स। जो सस्पिशियस इमेज को
एनालाइज़ करने का वर्क फ्लो है जो प्रोसेस
है उसको बहुत हद तक यह ऑटोमेट कर देता है।
वेदर यू आर अ एसओसी एनालिस्ट ट्रैगिंग
यूजर रिपेलिजेंस एनालिस्ट कलेक्टिंग
इंडिकेटर्स
अ रिस्चर इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग फिशिंग किट्स
फिश टूल ब्रिंग्स एवरीथिंग टुगेदर इन वन
प्लेस। तो पिश टूल का एक ऐसा ये टूल ऐसा
है जो एज एन एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट L1 L2 L3 जो
भी आप है आप इसको जरूर से जरूर यूज करेंगे
ही करेंगे थैंक यू सौम्यजीत एंड आई होप कि
एवरीवन इज लविंग इट भाई रिकॉर्डिंग
देखूंगी अभी आई एम रेदर बिजी नाउ सॉरी कोई
बात नहीं फाइनेंस कॉम कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
आप बाद में देख लीजिएगा नो इशूज़
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[हंसी]
सर यू आर सो इनोसेंट यू डोंट नो अच्छा कोई
बात में चलिए, तो फ्रिज टूल सब कुछ एक जगह
ला के रख देता है। कुछ इस तरह का आपको
यहां पे इंटरफ़ेस देखने को मिलता है। अब
यहां पे यह है कि यह भी पेड टूल है। एक
मतलब इनका भी पेड जो प्लान है वो यह ऑफर
करते हैं। बट सबसे अच्छी बात है इनका
कम्युनिटी एडिशन भी है। एंड कोई भी टूल जब
कम्युनिटी एडिशन में होती है तो बेस्ट
अपना लाइक एक प्लान बेस्ट प्लान इनका मतलब
कहा जा सकता है कम्युनिटी एडिशन क्योंकि
मोस्टली जो है सभी लोग इसको यूज़ करते हैं।
राइट अ टेस्टिंग के लिए या कम से कम
एटलीस्ट गेट उनको जानने के लिए एग्जैक्टली
हो क्या रहा है। राइट? तो ये चीज़ है। तो
यहां पे कम्युनिटी में बस यही वन यूजर है।
लिमिटेड कुछ एनालिसिस होती हैं। और जो
इनका एंटरप्राइज है इसमें अनलिमिटेड होता
है और इनका एक प्रोफेशनल भी शायद आने वाला
है। तो ये फिश टूल है। अब इसमें क्या है?
फिश टूल इज़ अ फॉरेंसिक एनालिसिस
प्लेटफार्म दैट हेल्प्स साइबर सिक्योरिटी
टीम्स ट्राय डसेक्ट एंड रिजॉल्व रिपोर्टेड
फिशिंग ईमेल्स क्विकली एक्यूरेटली एंड एट
अ स्केल। तो जो भी रिपोर्टेड फेसिंग
ईमेल्स हैं उनको जो है काफी बड़े लेवल पर
भी आप यहां पे इन्वेस्टिगेट कर सकते हैं।
फॉरेंसिक्स
का फॉरेंसिक्स एनालिसिस कर सकते हैं एंड
बहुत कुछ कर सकते हैं। सो दिस इज़ द टूल
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल। राइट?
अब इस टूल के अंदर क्या है? इसने
क्या-क्या कंबाइन किया है? थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस, ओसेंट, ईमेल मेटा डेटा,
ऑटोमेटेड एनालिसिस वर्क फ्लो, फिश टूल
प्रोवाइड्स अ सेंट्रलाइज्ड व्यू ऑफ़ फिशिंग
एक्टिविटी। ये एक सेंट्रलाइज व्यू देता है
फिशिंग एक्टिविटी का। अब यहां पे ये
क्या-क्या आर्टिफेक्ट्स को आइडेंटिफाई
करता है ये भी मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं।
अपॉन अपलोडिंग एन ईमेल टू फेस टूल। जब आप
एक ईमेल फेस टूल पे अपलोड करते हैं। यू आर
प्रेजेंटेड विद मेनी ऑफ़ द वैल्यूुएबल
आर्टिफेक्ट्स। बहुत सारे वैल्यूुएबल
जानकारी के साथ आपको चीजें मिलती है जो
यहां पे आपको दिख रही होंगी सामने। ऑन द
राइट हैंड साइड द टूल प्रोवाइड्स द
रेंडर्ड एचटीएमएल व्यू। सिमिलर टू व्हाट
यू वुड सी इन योर इनबॉक्स। द रॉ HTML एंड
आल्सो द मतलब राइट हैंड साइड में क्या
होता है? यह रेंडर्ड दिखाते हैं कि
एग्जैक्टली आपको ईमेल बॉक्स में वो ईमेल
कैसा आपको दिखेगा। कुछ इस तरीके से दिखेगा
भैया गेट मोर स्टोरेज करके ऐसा ईमेल में
आएगा। तो आपको सब कुछ ये सैंड बॉक्स
एनवायरमेंट दिखाते हैं। तो कोई टेंशन लेना
नहीं है। कुछ एकदम मस्त बिंदास करना है।
राइट
सर आई एम फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान। विल आई गेट द
सर्टिफिकेट फॉर एसओसी? नो ब्रदर उसके लिए
सॉरी। बट हम पाकिस्तान के स्टूडेंट्स को
सर्टिफिकेट नहीं दे रहे हैं। राइट? तो आप
कोर्स तो कर सकते हो। बिल्कुल आप यू आर
वेलकम। आप फ्री कोर्स है बिल्कुल करो। अह
उसके लिए तो हम आपको मना भी नहीं कर सकते।
YouTube पे है। आप यू कैन डू। बट हम
सर्टिफिकेट जो है वो पाकिस्तान के अह जो
भी ऑडियंस है या जो भी स्टूडेंट्स हैं
उनको हम प्रोवाइड नहीं कर रहे हैं। अ तो
आप अभी नॉलेज लो गेन करो। ठीक है?
ओके। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] तो यहां पे
अपॉन ये तो आ गया आपका। यहां पे इस तरीके
का कुछ आपने अपलोड किया है। अब यहां पे
कुछ इस तरीके की पूरी डिटेल जो है पूरी
पूरी डिटेल वह आपको यहां पे प्रोवाइड
किया। सर ये तो गलत हो गया। क्या गलत हो
गया बताइए? साइबर जैन जी क्या गलत हो गया?
चलिए ठीक है। तो इस तरीके से पूरी डिटेल
यहां पे आती है। योर क्लाउड स्पेससेस ठीक
है? हटाओ। यहां पे फ्रॉम डिस्प्ले नेम
सेंडर टू सीसी इन रिप्लाई टू टाइम स्टैंप
रिप्लाई टू मैसेज आईडी रिटर्न पाथ
ओरिजनेटिंग आईपी हर चीज जो है आपका डीएनएस
वगैरह सब कुछ आपको जानकारी मिलेगी फदर
एनालिसिस की बात करें तो यहां पे है बाय
नेविगेटिंग द टैब्स अक्रॉस द टॉप ऑफ फिश
टूल यू कैन एनालाइज की कंपोनेंट्स ऑफ द
ईमेल आप ईमेल के की कॉमोनेंट्स को ठीक है
आप एनालाइज कर सकते हैं इंक्लूडिंग
ऑथेंटिकेशन रिजल्ट्स ट्रांसमिशन पाथ्स एंड
एनी एंबेडेड यूआरएल्स। तो आप सारी डिटेल्स
वगैरह एंबेडेड यूआरएल्स के और सब चीजें
यहां पे आप पता कर सकते हैं। इफ द ईमेल
कंटेंस अटैचमेंट्स। अगर ईमेल में कोई
अटैचमेंट है तो वो भी आप रिव्यू कर सकते
हैं और डायरेक्ट एनालाइज़ कर सकते हैं। कुछ
इस तरीके से जैसे यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
यहां पे ये तो डिटेल आई थी। यहां पे आपको
हॉप वन हॉप टू यहां पे रिसीव फॉर्म ये सब
आ रही है। यूआरएल की भी डिटेल सारी
यूआरएल्स वगैरह ये सारी चीजें आपको देखने
को मिलेगी। वन ऑफ़ द फिश टूल्स स्टैंड आउट
फीचर इज़ इट्स इंटीग्रेशन विथ वायरस टोटल।
अब इसका वायरस टोटल के साथ इंटीग्रेशन है
भैया अलाउंग यू टू व्यू रेपुटेशन एंड
डिटेक्शन रिजल्ट्स विदाउट लिविंग द टूल
मतलब आपको क्या है रेपुटेशन मतलब आप सीधा
इसका रेपुटेशन जो भी आपका फाइल ई या जो भी
यूआरएल वगैरह है उसका आप रेपुटेशन वगैरह
चेक कर सकते हैं यहीं से वायरस टोटल पे भी
जाने की जरूरत नहीं है इंटीग्रेशन है इनका
वायरस टोटल के साथ ठीक है तो कुछ इस तरीके
से जैसे यहां पे यूआरएल्स डोमेनस ये वायरस
टोटल का स्कोर आपको बताएगा कि 94 में से
कितने डिटेक्शन वगैरह हुए हैं क्या हुए
हैं ये आपको बताएगा कि लास्ट में यहां पे
कितने एक लाइक 94 में से एक ने वो किया है
तो मतलब ऑलमोस्ट ये सेफ जो है ये
है आपका फाइल इस तरीके से ये बताएगा ठीक
है ऑलाइट
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके नहीं नहीं यार मैंने बोला मैंने
पाकिस्तान के उसके लिए बोला कि पाकिस्तान
वाले को ही सिर्फ सर्टिफिकेट नहीं मिलेगी।
पाकिस्तान से जो भी बिलोंग करते हैं। बट
आप लोग फिर भी ट्रेनिंग यह वाला कर सकते
हैं। फ्री ऑफ़ कॉस्ट अवेलेबल है। यू कैन
ठीक है
या सर आफ्टर डूइंग द हैकिंग कोर्स ऑफ़
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी? कैन आई डू सिक्योरिटी
प्लस और ईजेपीटी एंड व्हिच सर्टिफिकेट इज़
बेस्ट सर? व्हिच शुड आई गो सिक्योरिटी
प्लस, ईजेपीटी, सीपीटी
अह और एनी सर्टिफिकेशन ऑफ़ हैव डन द जॉब
ओके हां मैंने तो मेरी जॉब के लिए पूछ रहे
हो तो हां मैंने जॉब किया है पहले और
कोर्सर्सेस की बात कर रहे हो तो आप हमारा
जो डीईएई मॉड्यूल है डीईएई का जो
प्लेलिस्ट है हमारे YouTube पे उसको प्लीज
आप देखिए उसके थ्रू आप ईजीपीटी जैसे
सर्टिफिकेशंस क्लियर कर सकते हैं। बहुत ही
इंटरेस्टिंग प्लेलिस्ट है। बहुत ही डिटेल
है। उसको जरूर देखिएगा। साथ ही में अगर
आपको टाइम मिले जब भी तो आप बग बंटी की
प्लेलिस्ट देख लीजिएगा। एंड एक जॉब
ओरिएंटेड ट्रेनिंग के लिए अगर आपको जॉब के
लिए उस तरीके का ट्रेनिंग देखना है तो
वीएपीटी की हमारी डीसीएपीटी ट्रेनिंग होती
है। लाइव ट्रेनिंग होती है। वो आप ज्वाइन
कर सकते हैं। उसकी नेक्स्ट बैच की भी
अनाउंसमेंट बहुत जल्दी आ जाएगी। ठीक है?
ओके।
सर सर्टिफिकेट का मसला नहीं है। आई बिलीव
इन स्किल्स। बहुत बढ़िया बात है। तभी
मैंने बोला कि सर्टिफिकेट से क्या होगा?
आप स्किल्स को गेन करने में लगो ना।
स्किल्स के ऊपर काम करो। राइट?
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] देखते हैं।
अब देखते हैं रिजॉल्विंग द
रिजॉल्विंग द केस। वंस योर एनालिसिस इज
कंप्लीट फिश टूल अलाउ यू टू फॉर्मली
डॉक्यूमेंट योर फाइंडिंग्स। मतलब जब आपकी
एनालिसिस कंप्लीट हो जाएगी तो ये
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन में भी हेल्प करता है फिश
टूल। तो फिश टूल अपने आप में एक बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है। याद रखिएगा। और हो
सकता है इस टूल को यूज़ आपको करना पड़े।
बीइंग एन एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट यू मस्ट बी और
माइट बी यूजिंग दिस टूल। आप में से कोई
ऐसा एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट यहां पे है जिसने
फिश टूल को यूज़ करा हो। पहले एनीवन कोई है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके नोबडी
नो अभी किसी ने यूज़ नहीं करा है। कोई बात
नहीं आपको यूज़ करने का मौका मिलेगा। हो
सकता है। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एज़ शोन बिलो इन ईमेल कैन बी मार्क्ड एज
मलेशियस विद की आर्टिफेक्ट सच ऐज़ सेंडर
एड्रेस ओरिजिनेटिंग आईपी मेडेड यूआरएल्स
टू बी फ्लैग्ड। यू कैन देन ऐड
इन्वेस्टिगेशन नोट्स एंड क्लिक द रिज़ॉल्व।
ठीक है? तो, आप जैसे यह एक ईमेल को यहां
पे इसने मलिशियस फ़्लैग किया है। यहां पे
फ्रॉम ईमेल, डोमेन सब कुछ डिटेल आपको दी
गई है। यहां पे क्लासिफिकेशन मोड क्या
दिया है? मलेशियस यूआरएल दिया है। अब यहां
पे आप अपना कुछ नोट डालिए और रिज़ॉल्व कर
दीजिए। तो
ये एक रियल एसओसी एनवायरमेंट में केस
क्लोज़र प्रोसेस में यूज़ में आता है। जब आप
रियल एसओसी एनवायरमेंट में काम कर रहे
होंगे तो केस क्लोज़र प्रोसेस में आप इसका
यूज़ करके एक अच्छा डॉक्यूमेंट जो है वो
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन भी आपका हो गया और आप
रिज़ॉल्व कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? ये बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज़ है। अकॉर्डिंग टू द वायरस
टोटल एनालिसिस फ्रॉम अबव व्हिच वेंडर
कैटेगराइज़ द यूआरएल एज़ फिशिंग। अब ऊपर का
जो वायरस टोटल का रिजल्ट है जैसे ये सारी
तो कौन सा इसको फिशिंग डिक्लेअ करता है
भैया? तो देखो ये सारे अनडिटेक्टेड है। एक
ने फिशिंग डिक्लेअ किया है। सेफ टू ओपन।
यह हमारा वेंडर है। तो आंसर हो जाएगा
हमारा सॉरी सेफ टू ओपन।
यह माइक है रोड एंटी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] रोड मिनी एंटी
यूएसबी।
ठीक है। चलिए कोई बात नहीं है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब आते हैं यहां पे। योर अकाउंट इज़ ऑन
होल्ड वाली। उस पे क्या है यह? योर अकाउंट
इज़ ऑन होल्ड। यह क्या है? बेसिकली टू
सक्सेसफुली कंप्लीट दिस यू नीड टू सेट अप
द वर्चुअल एनवायरमेंट। आपको अटैकर मशीन और
लैब मशीन दोनों स्टार्ट करनी पड़ेगी। अब
यहां पे क्या है? इन दिस सिनेरियो यू आर अ
लेवल वन एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट एज़ द फर्स्ट
लाइन ऑफ़ डिफेंस यू हैव टू आइडेंटिफाई
फिशिंग एंड स्पैम ईमेल्स रिपोर्टेड बाय
एंड यूज़र्स। आपको आइडेंटिफाई करना है
फिशिंग एंड स्पैम ईमेल्स को एज़ एन एसोसिएल
वन। इन द फॉलोइंग टास्क यू विल स्टेप इंटू
द रोल एंड एनालाइज़ मल्टीपल सस्िशियस
ईमेल्स दैट हैव बीन एस्केलेटेड ब
कोवर्कर्स। अब जो भी कोवर्कर्स हैं आपके
उन्होंने सस्िशियस ईमेल्स को एक तरह से
क्या किया है? एस्केलेट किया है। उसको
आपको देखना है। योर ऑब्जेक्टिव इज़ टू
केयरफुली रिव्यू ईच ईमेल एक्सट्रैक्ट की
इंडिकेटर्स एंड आइडेंटिफाई एनी साइन ऑफ़
मलेशियस एक्टिविटी। आपका यह काम है कि आप
सारे जो ईमेल है उसको अच्छे से रिव्यू
कीजिए। उससे की इंडिकेटर्स निकालिए और
किसी भी तरह का मलेशियस साइन है तो बताइए।
द फाइंडिंग यू अनकवर विल हेल्प योर टीम
डेवलप डिटेक्शन रूल्स टू प्रिवेंट सिमिलर
थ्रेट्स फ्रॉम रीचिंग अदर यूजर्स इन
फ्यूचर। तो आपकी फाइंडिंग पे ही एक
डिटेक्शन रूल तैयार किया जाएगा जो कि
फर्दर फ्यूचर में अभी ऐसे अटैक्स ना हो
उसका वो ध्यान रखेगी। डिटेक्शन रूल में उस
चीज का ध्यान रखा जाएगा। तो सबसे पहले हम
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे अ बेसिकली अ
मशीन को स्टार्ट करते हैं। तो अटैक बॉक्स
को हम स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं।
ये हमारा स्टार्ट स्टार्ट हो रहा है अटैक
बॉक्स। एंड देन हम लैब मशीन को भी स्टार्ट
कर लेते हैं। अटैक बॉक्स जो है आप एज एन
अटैकर आपका मशीन है और लैब मशीन तो आपका
जो मेन मशीन है आपका जिस पे आप काम कर रहे
हैं वह है। ठीक है? तो लेट्स स्टार्ट इट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अभी तक क्लियर है ना गाइस सब कुछ?
बहुत ही स्ट्रक्चर वे में मैं आपको ये
चीजें करा रहा हूं ताकि थोड़ी आपको चीजें
नई-नई पता चले। क्लेरिटी मिलता चले। आपको
चीजें क्लियर होती चले। आप रेडी हो रहे
हो। ऑलमोस्ट बहुत बहुत सारी चीजें आप आपके
अंदर ऑलरेडी रेडी हो चुकी है। एसओसीएल वन
के तौर पे कई सारी चीजें आपको ज्यादा पता
है एज एन एसओसीएल वन।
सो
ओके लेट इट स्टार्ट स्टार्टिंग चलिए
स्टार्ट होगा ये यहां पे क्या है यहां पे
अ टू बिगिन क्लिक द स्टार्ट लैब मशीन ठीक
है एंड डेस्कटॉप पे ओपन कर करना है आपका
फिश थ्री केस वन ईएमएल ठीक है? फ्रॉम देयर
बिगिन योर इन्वेस्टिगेशन। ठीक है? तो यह
डेस्कटॉप पे फाइल होगी। अ ठीक है? इसको
स्टार्ट करना है अपने को। लेट्स सी। इसको
मैं न्यू टैब में ओपन कर लेता हूं। व्यू
इन फुल फुल स्क्रीन न्यू टैब में आ जाएगी।
इसको थोड़ा बड़ा कर देते हैं।
अच्छा चलो कोई बात नहीं। ये हो गया। इसको
हम क्लोज कर देते हैं। यहां पे डेस्कटॉप
पे
ओके। सो वेयर इज द फाइल?
अच्छा ये रहा ये तो फिशिंग ये वाला है ना
ये वाला फिशिंग इमेज मैंने वो ओपन कर दिया
था। सॉरी ये वाली है।
ठीक? यह आपका फाइल है। फिश 3ksm। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इसको स्टार्ट करना है। लेट्स स्टार्ट इट।
स्टार्टिंग
क्या हुआ भाई?
मैं फिर से ओपन करता हूं। हां चलो स्टार्ट
हो गया।
अच्छा दो-दो बार हो गई है। स्टार्ट ठीक
है।
ये रहा। कुछ इस तरीके से ये मेल आपको यहां
पे देखने को मिल रहा है। ठीक है? अब यहां
आ रहा है द डोमेनस यूआरएल एंड आईपी
एड्रेसेस रेफरेंस इन दिस टास्क हैव
होस्टेड अ रियल मलेशियस कंटेंट एंड मे
स्टिल पोज़ अ रिस्क। डू नॉट एक्सेस और
इंटैक्ट विद देम आउटसाइड द कंट्रोल। मतलब
इसमें जो डोमेन ईमेल और जो भी है वो एक
रियल मतलब मलशियस कंटेंट होस्ट करते हैं।
तो आपको अपने सिस्टम पे ये सब डाउनलोड
वलोड करके मजा नहीं करना है। इसी में जो
करना है करना है भाई। ठीक है? तो इस चीज
का ध्यान रखिएगा। व्हाट रेपिटेबल ब्रांड
इन दिस ईमेल टेलर्ड टू इंपर्सनेट? कौन से
रेपिटेड ब्रांड को इंपर्सनेट यानी कि
मिमिक करने की कोशिश की गई है? तो ऑब्वियस
सी बात है ये Netflix की तरफ से भेजा जा
रहा है। तो Netflix को ही इंपर्सनेट किया
जा रहा है। तो Netflix लिख दो।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[संगीत] बेस्ड ऑन द ईमेल हेडर्स? हु इज द
इंटेंडेंट रिसिपिएंट ऑफ दिस मैसेज? इसका
रिसिपिएंट कौन है? ईमेल हेडर के तौर पे।
तो रिसिपिएंट कौन है? यह है भाई कॉपी ईमेल
एड्रेस रिडक्टेड@yahoo.com
ठीक है इन [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
थंडरब मेल यूज मेल थंडरबर्ट मेल में आपको
यह जो है थंडरबर्ड मेल है ये आपको व्यू
मैसेज सोर्स पे जाना है व्हाट इज द
रिसीव्ड फ्रॉम IPपी एड्रेस आपको व्यू पे
जाना है मैसेज सोर्स पे जाना है
इस पे आना है और इसमें क्या है रिसीव्ड
फ्रॉम एड्रेस क्या है तो रिसीव्ड फ्रॉम
में यहां पे एड्रेस यह वाला है बस कॉपी
पेस्ट
चेक कर लेते हैं। सही है। चेक आउट द
रिटर्न पाथ फील्ड इन द मैसेज सोर्स। व्हाट
वुड यू कंसीडर अ डोमेन ऑफ इंटरेस्ट बेस्ड
ऑन दिस फील्ड? यहां पे आ रहा है कि आपको
देखना है कि रिटर्न पाथ जो है वो देखिए
क्या है इनका? तो चलिए यहां पे इनका
रिटर्न पाथ देख लेते हैं। सो हियर हियर
हियर हियर हियर
अह
अरे यार कहां गया? ये रिटर्न पाथ आपका
यहां पे ये रहा और इसमें डोमेन कौन सा है?
तो डोमेन आपका
यही वाला तो डोमेन होगा ना ये वाला ये
वाला एनोxyz
डोमेन तो इसी को बोलते हैं ए टेक्नो ये तो
ईमेल है पोस्ट मास्टर ए टेक्नो करके है
ठीक है तो ये डोमेन यहां पे हमारे
इंटरेस्ट का है तो ये हमने डोमेन यहां पे
डाल दिया चेक हो गई
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके इन्वेस्टिगेट द अपडेट अकाउंट नाउ बटन
व्हाट इज द शॉर्ट एंड यूआरएल अब इस अपडेट
अकाउंट नाउ बटन को इन्वेस्टिगेट करना है
ठीक है तो इसका शॉर्ट एंड यूआरएल क्या
क्या है? तो चलिए अपडेट अकाउंट नाउ को हम
इन्वेस्टिगेट करते हैं। कंट्रोल एफ करते
हैं। यहां पे देखते हैं अपडेट अकाउंट नाउ
का कुछ है क्या? कुछ भी नहीं है। राइट? तो
यहां पे बटन कुछ है बटन। हां। तो यहां पे
हमें बटन मिला है यहां पे। ठीक है? नाइस।
यहां पे ये हमें बटन मिला है।
ठीक है?
तो अपडेट अकाउंट नाउ पे ही करते हैं। ये
रहा अपडेट अकाउंट नाउ। राइट। इसको हम
इन्वेस्टिगेट करते हैं। तो हम इसको क्लिक
करते हैं। इसको ओपन करते हैं।
स्टार्ट हो जा भाई जल्दी से।
अपडेट अकाउंट नाउ। अरे भाई ओपन हो जा।
ओपन हो रहा है। ये थोड़ा टाइम लेता है।
लेगा ओपन मतलब ले रहा था ओपन होने में। तो
ये मल्टीपल टैब्स खुल गए हैं। इसको मैं
सारे क्लोज कर देता हूं।
कुछ इस तरीके से है।
तो ये तो एक शॉर्ट एंड यूआरएल है। ये आपको
दिख रहा होगा ऊपर में। ये शॉर्ट एंड
यूआरएल है। आई थिंक इसका कुछ ना कुछ तो
होगा। ये देखो इन्वेस्टिगेट अपडेट अकाउंट
वर्ड। नाउ व्हाट इज द शॉर्ट एंड यूआरएल?
तो शॉर्टेन यूआरएल तो यही है। ये जो ओपन
हो रहा है ये दिस इज अ शॉर्ट एंड यूआरएल।
लेट्स चेक इफ इट इज करेक्ट। हां यही है
शॉर्ट एंड यूआरएल। राइट? बहुत सिंपल।
अपडेट पेमेंट डिटेल्स। अब आते हैं अपडेट
पेमेंट डिटेल्स पे। इन दिस टास्क यू विल
इन्वेस्टिगेट अ मशसियस अटैचमेंट यूजिंग
एनी रन। हम एनी रन का यूज़ करके एक मशियस
अटैचमेंट जो है उसको हम इन्वेस्टिगेट करने
वाले हैं इस टास्क के अंदर में। इसको
क्लोज़ कर देते हैं। दिस इज़ अ सस्पेक्टेड
फिशिंग ईमेल मैस्कुडरेटिंग एज अ मतलब एक
सस्पेक्टेड फिशिंग ईमेल है जो
मैस्क्यूरेडिंग एज अ Netflix पेमेंट अपडेट
नोटिफिकेशन जो कि अपने आप को दिखा रहा है
कि एक Netflix पेमेंट अपडेट नोटिफिकेशन
है। यूजिंग द प्रोवाइडेड सैंड बॉक्स
रिव्यू द फाइल्स बिहेवियर नेटवर्क
एक्टिविटी एंड एनी इंडिकेटर ऑफ़
कॉम्प्रोमाइज़ पे क्लोज अटेंशन टू द हाउ द
अटैचमेंट एग्जीक्यूट्स एंड इंटरेक्ट्स विथ
द सिस्टम। ठीक है? अब देखो द डोमेन यूआरएल
फिर वही बात है। चलिए हाउ डस एनी रन
क्लासिफाई दिस सस्पेक्टेड फिशिंग ईमेल? तो
यहां पे सैंड बॉक्स को ओपन कर लेते हैं।
ये ओपन हो रहा है यहां पे
जो दिया हुआ है यहां पे हमने ओपन कर लिया।
यह एनी रन में ओपन हो रहा है हमारा जो
क्या ओपन हो रहा है यहां पे? मलेशियस
अटैचमेंट Netflix वाली। ठीक है? जो पेमेंट
बेसिकली यह फिशिंग ईमेल है जो कि Netflix
का पेमेंट अपडेट नोटिफिकेशन का वो कर रहा
है। तो देखो यहां पे यहां पे आ रहा है
प्लीज
यहां पर है ना प्लीज अपडेट योर पेमेंट
डिटेल्स हाई कस्टमर वी आर हैबिंग ऐसे
करके। तो ये इस तरीके से ही एनी रन में
आपको पूरी डिटेल में ऐसे कुछ इस तरीके से
आपको देखने को मिलती है। पूरी डिटेल में
आप देख रहे हैं कितनी डिटेल यहां पे आपको
चीज़ देखने को मिल रही है। तो, यहां पे आ
रहा है, हाउ डज़ एनी रन क्लासिफाई दिस
सस्पेक्टेड फ़िशिंग ईमेल? ए अह मतलब एनी रन
जो है इसको क्या कैसे क्लासिफ़ाई कर रहा
है? क्या क्लासिफ़िकेशन इसकी करी है? तो
पेमेंट रिसीव pdf ही तो फाइल है ये वाली।
ये फाइल है यहां पे। राइट? इस फाइल पे हम
क्लिक करते हैं। इस फाइल पे हम जब हम
क्लिक करेंगे तो यहां पे आपको इस फाइल की
पूरी डिटेल्स जो है वो देखने को मिलेंगी।
लाइक व्हाटएवर डिटेल्स आर देयर आपको यहां
पे देखने को मिलेगा। यहां पे नीचे में
यहां पे हैशेज़ आपको देखने को मिलेंगे।
यहां पे फाइल आइडेंटिफायर देखने को
मिलेगा। यहां पे फाइल की कुछ डिटेल साइज
वगैरह ये सब सारी चीजें एप्लीकेशन और टाइप
क्या है ये सारी चीजें यहां पे देखने को
मिलेंगे। अब यहीं पे आपको देखने को मिलेगा
सबसे ऊपर में सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी। यहां पे
आपको देखने को मिल रहा है सस्िशियस
एक्टिविटी।
ये चीज आपको मिलेगी देखने को। यहां पे कुछ
अह
इंडिकेटर्स यहां पे देखने को मिलेंगे।
लाइक अह डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ इंडिकेटर्स यहां
पे आपको। और यहां पे लेफ्ट साइड में यह
एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट आपको देखने को
मिलेंगे। जो भी इसके एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट
है, कनेक्शंस आपको देखने को मिलेंगे। कुछ
इस तरीक़े से सारे प्रोसेससेस के नाम,
प्रोटोकॉल्स, IPपी एड्रेस जो एसोसिएटेड
है, डोमेनस एसोसिएटेड है, वह सारे देखने
को मिलेंगे। डीएनएस के रिक्वेस्ट देखने को
मिलेंगे। जो भी डीएनएस सर्वर्स के
रिक्वेस्ट हैं और नेटवर्क थ्रेट्स का यहां
पे आपको देखने को मिलेगा। तो, ये सारी
चीजें आपको देखने को मिलेंगे। तो, यहां पे
आपका आ रहा है कि क्लासिफाई क्या किया
इन्होंने? तो यहां पे सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी
क्लासिफाई किया है। तो हम यहां पे
सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी कर देंगे।
दैट्स इट। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
व्हाट इज द नेम ऑफ़ द पीडीएफ अटैचमेंट?
पीडीएफ अटैचमेंट का नाम क्या है? तो ये तो
यहां दिया हुआ है भाई कि ये नाम है पेमेंट
अपडेटेड पीडीएफ। है ना? पेमेंट अपडेटेड
पीडीएफ। तो हम यहां पे इसका नाम डाल देते
हैं। ठीक है? इन्वेस्टिगेट द ईमेल
अटैचमेंट। ईमेल ये अटैचमेंट जो है इसको
इन्वेस्टिगेट करना है। और बोल रहा है
व्हाट इज़ द एसए 256#श ऑफ़ द पीडीएफ फाइल?
एसए 256 हैश क्या है? तो मैंने पहले ही
बोला इसके लिए आपको इसी पीडीएफ पे क्लिक
करनी है। तो आपको एसएचए की वैल्यूज़ मिल
जाएंगी। आपको यहां दिखेगा एसए 256। एसएचए
वन, एमडी5, एसए 256 ये सारे आपको मिलेंगे।
तो, एसएसए 256 वाले को हम यहां से कॉपी कर
लेते हैं और यहां पे डाल देते हैं। दैट्स
इट। हो गया। राइट?
चेक आउट द एनी रन टेक्स्ट रिपोर्ट ऑन द
फिशिंग मेल। आपको एनी रन का अह टेक्स्ट
चाहिए। इससे देखो, मैं यह जो चीज़ आपको बता
रहा हूं, भले हम यह लैब में देख रहे हैं,
बट लैब की चीज़ ही हम रियल लाइफ़ में भी
उसको यूज़ करते हैं। तो, यह जो एनालिसिस आप
देख रहे हैं, जो एनी रन यूज़ कर रहे हैं,
तो आप जब रियल में एनी रडन को यूज़ करेंगे,
तो आप सेम तरीके से यूज़ करेंगे। तो, बस
आपको ध्यान देना है थोड़ा सा। अभी ध्यान दे
दीजिएगा, बाद में आपको मजे आएंगे। टेक्स्ट
रिपोर्ट चेक करना है एनी रडन का। व्हिच
आईपी एड्रेस एसोसिएटेड विद द प्रोसेस
एक्रो आरडी 32 इज फ्लैग्ड एज मलेशियस। एक
प्रोसेस है एकro आरडी 32 तो कौन सी आईपी
एड्रेस इससे एसोसिएटेड है? ठीक है? ये पता
करना है तो हम इसका टेक्स्ट रिपोर्ट
देखेंगे। ठीक है? एकro आरडी तो यहां पे आप
देख सकते हैं एकro आरडी 32.xec
एक फाइल यहां पे आपको दिख रही है। यहां पे
दो बेसिकली प्रोसेस दिख रहे हैं। दो जो कि
आपको ये फाइल होस्ट करती है। तो अब हम
क्या करते हैं यहां पे? पे इसका टेक्स्ट
रिपोर्ट जो है इसको हम एक बार देखने की
कोशिश करते हैं। यहां पे ये रिजल्ट्स
वगैरह हैं ये सारे यहां पे टायर वन
रिपोर्ट और ये सब आएगा। बट अब हमें इस
फाइल के लिए मान लो देखना है हमें इस फाइल
के स्पेसिफिक अ डिटेल्स हमें जाननी है।
ठीक है? तो अब हम क्या करेंगे यहां पे
जैसे यहां इसके थोड़े मल्टीपल तरीके हैं।
मैं आपको वैसे दिखा देता हूं। जैसे मान लो
हमने http रिक्वेस्ट को देखा। ठीक है? तो
इसमें एक फाइल आ रही है एकro rd.exec राइट
यहां पे देखने को मिल रहा है। इसको हम
यहां पे थोड़ा सा स्लाइड करेंगे ऐसे करके
यहां पे। तो इसकी और डिटेल्स यहां पे आपको
देखने को मिल जाएगी। तो मैं पहले एक
प्रोसेस नेम एकro आईडी फर्स्ट वाला। ठीक
है? इसको हम ओपन कर लेते हैं। यहां पे आप
देख सकते हैं इसका स्कोर क्या है? इसका
स्कोर जिसका प्रोसेस आईडी 2088 है वो है
50 आउट ऑफ 100। यानी यह मलेशियस कैटेगरी
में है। अब यह जो है एक और प्रोसेस है
3368 का जिसका नाम है एकrod 32 ही नाम है।
अब इसको भी ओपन करके देख लेते हैं। इसका
स्कोर है ज़ीरो। तो, यहां दो प्रोसेससेस
हैं सेम नाम से। ठीक है? तो हो सकता है एक
रियल प्रोसेस हो और दूसरा प्रोसेस जो हो
वो उस मलेशियस फाइल ने मिमिक करके कॉपी
करके एक मलशियस प्रोसेस सेम टाइम का बना
दिया हो। तो आप रियल प्रोसेस पे अगर
इन्वेस्टिगेट करेंगे तो अपना टाइम वेस्ट
करेंगे कोई फायदा नहीं है। राइट? उसका कोई
मतलब मतलब नहीं है। तो आपको देखना है
स्कोर क्या है? तो अब स्कोर इसका जीरो है
तो इस पे तो हमें कुछ फायदा ही नहीं है।
इस पे हमें
कुछ नहीं करना है। मतलब कुछ भी नहीं करना
है। अब यहां पे करना है इस वाले पे जिसको
हम 50 वाले जो स्कोर है उस पे आना है।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] अब
यहां जब हम आएंगे तो यहां पे अब हमारा
क्या क्वेश्चन है भैया कि कौन सा आईपी
एड्रेस एसोसिएटेड है? तो अब इसकी हमें
थोड़ी डिटेल चाहिए। तो यहां पे हमें मोर
इनफो पे क्लिक करना है। मोर इनफो पे क्लिक
करेंगे तो इसकी पूरी डिटेल जो है आपके
सामने आ जाएगी। अरे हो जा। हां। यह आ गई
हमारे पास। ठीक है? यह सस्पिशियस आ रहा
है। अब IP एड्रेस एसोसिएटेड कौन सा है जो
मलेशियस फ्लैग हुआ है? तो देखो IPपी
एड्रेसेस के लिए मान लो मैं यहां पे चलता
हूं कनेक्शंस में। कनेक्शंस में चले तो
हमें यहां पे कनेक्शंस इसके सारे जो है
कनेक्शंस दिखेंगे। सॉरी जो भी कनेक्शंस है
वो दिखेंगे। एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट में
जाएंगे तो आपको एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट जो है
वो सारी दिखेंगी। यहां पे आप
सिंक्रोनाइजेशन ये सब छोड़ो। मॉडिफाइड
फाइल्स में मॉडिफाइड जो फाइल्स वगैरह हुई
हैं वो सारी आपको दिखेंगी। ठीक है? तो
यहां पे रजिस्ट्री चेंजज़ में रजिस्ट्री
चेंजज़ जो हुई हैं इससे इसके रिगार्डिंग वो
सारी आपको चीजें अ
देखेंगे। उसके बाद यहां कनेक्शंस में अब
आएंगे तो हमें IP एड्रेसेस देखने को
मिलेंगे। तो आपको दिख रहा होगा यहां पे ये
जो IPपी एड्रेस है फर्स्ट वाली यह एक IPपी
एड्रेस है यहां पे अकाम इंटरनेशनल ऐसे
करके। तो इसको हम ऐसे देख सकते हैं कि
जैसे अ लेट्स सपोज कि यहां कनेक्शंस में
मुझे मल्टीपल IPपी एड्रेसेस यहां पे दिख
रही हैं। जिसकी कि सारी डिटेल्स वगैरह आ
रही है। सब कुछ आ रही है यहां पे। यहां पे
कंट्री का यहां पे इसका कुछ पता नहीं है।
अननोन है। अननोन है। ठीक है? अब यहां पे
मैं इस IPपी एड्रेस ये जो IPपी एड्रेस है।
अब इसको मैं ऐसे देख सकता हूं कि यहां से
तो मैंने चलो यहां से तो आपने जो भी है
एनालिसिस है वो सब कर लिया। मान लो। अब इस
रिपोर्ट को मैं यहां से थोड़ा सा पीछे हो
जाता हूं। यहां से बैक हो जाता हूं। यहां
से वापस से 2808 वाली हमारी थी जो प्रोसेस
जिस पर हम काम कर रहे थे। तो यानी यह वाली
2808 वाली प्रोसेस है। आजा भाई
2808 वाली। अब इससे एसोसिएटेड सॉरी सॉरी
वो चलते हैं कनेक्शंस पे। अब यहां
कनेक्शंस आपको यहां पे भी देखने को मिल
जाएगा। राइट? यहां पे भी सारी डिटेल्स
वगैरह जो भी चीजें हैं यहां पे आपको देखने
को मिल जाएगा। अब यहां पे जब आप इसको
थोड़ा सा सॉरी ऐसे करेंगे यहां पे तो यहां
पे आपको डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट IPपी एड्रेससेस
देखने को मिल जाएगी। अब ये जो IPपी
एड्रेसेस है ये पर्टिकुलर IP एड्रेस। सो
दिस इज़ द IPपी एड्रेस दैट इज़ सस्पिशियस।
दैट इज़ द मशियस IPपी एड्रेस जो इससे
एसोसिएटेड है। किससे एसोसिएटेड है? हमारे
उससे एकro अह एकro RD 32.exe से। तो इस
तरीके से हम डिटेल्स मतलब उसकी पता कर
सकते हैं। लाइक अब मुझे मान लो इसके बारे
में थोड़ा और वैसे जानकारी चाहिए तो वैसे
ही सेम सेम चीजें हैं यहां पे मोर इनफो
करेंगे तो आपको सारी जानकारी वगैरह सारी
चीजें जो है वो आपको मिल जाएगी। तो मोर
इनफो पे फिर से वही सारी डिटेल्स और
व्हाटएवर इनेशन इज़ देयर ये सारी चीजें। तो
अभी तो हमको 282022 वाला तो यह वाला हम
अभी कर रहे हैं। अब इसमें आपको जैसे कि इस
फ़ाइल की इसकी पूरी तो एक डिटेल आपको मिलती
है। यहां पे इंडिकेटर्स आपको
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट जो इंडिकेटर्स से रिलेटेड
जो चीजें हैं वो आपको सारी मिलेंगी यहां
पे। व्यू में आप ग्रुप और डीप दोनों व्यू
आप देख सकते हैं। लाइक कौन सा एक डीप व्यू
का एक अलग थोड़ा सा व्यू आएगा। ग्रुप वाला
व्यू का थोड़ा अलग व्यू आएगा यहां पे इस
तरीके से। और उसके साथ आप इधर के इवेंट्स
देख सकते हैं कि भैया मॉडिफाइड कौन-कौन सी
हुई है। जैसे मैंने बताया एचटीटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट में अब सिंक्रोनाइजेशन में देखो
रजिस्ट्री चेंजज़ में हो सकती है। मॉडिफाइड
फाइल्स में आपको अलग-अलग फाइल्स जो है वो
मॉडिफाइड आपको दिख सकती है। यहां पे डीबग
करेंगे तो डीबग का डिटेल्स कुछ होगा।
मॉड्यूल्स होगा तो मॉड्यूल से रिलेटेड कोई
जानकारी होंगी वो होगी। नेटवर्क थ्रेट्स
अगर कोई है तो नेटवर्क थ्रेट्स होंगी।
कनेक्शंस जो होंगी तो कोई कनेक्शंस होंगी।
तो ये आईपी हम यहां पे पुट करते हैं। एंड
लेट्स सी।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सो
आईपी एड्रेस यह IP फिलहाल तो नहीं है।
एकro RD 32 यह फ्लैग्ड एज़ मलेशियस नहीं
है। सो लेट्स सी व्हिच आईपी इज़ मलेशियस
अ दिस वन
हम उसी पे है ना? नहीं इस पे तो यह तो
नहीं है।
चलिए इसको देख लेते हैं। क्रिएट ओपन ठीक
है। क्रिएट ओपन है। मशस टैग मलेशियस का
यह तो रजिस्ट्री से रिलेटेड है जिसका कोई
खास मतलब नहीं है।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़][गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
बाइनरी है यहां पे डीआईआर है कंप्रेस्ड
है। ठीक है?
ओके इसका देखते हैं। इसमें कुछ मशियस कोई
आईपी है जो मलेशियस कैटेगरी में हुई हो।
रजिस्ट्री चेंजज़ है यहां पे। इसमें तो कुछ
है नहीं। मॉडिफाइड फाइल्स मॉडिफाइड है।
बाइनरी बाइनरी। ठीक है? रजिस्ट्री चेंज
में नॉर्मल रजिस्ट्री चेंज है। दिस वाज़
आल्सो नॉट आवर द मेन मेन हमारा मलेशियस तो
यही वाला था। राइट
एचटीपी रिक्वेस्ट हां एसटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
में चलते हैं।
ठीक है? एंड दिस इज़ द कॉम्रेस फाइल मैसेज
यहां पे अननोन है। यूनाइटेड स्टेट्स।
यूनाइटेड स्टेट्स में है। डीजी अच्छा डीजी
सर्ट Windows अपडेट यह कौन सी फाइल है?
डिसअऊ करके देखा। यह है Windows अपडेट
Amazon ठीक है। D करके ठीक है। इसमें कुछ
खास हमें
यहां पे है कि फ्लैग मलिशियस फ्लैग कौन सा
हुआ है? जो acro RD 32.exc प्रोसेस से वो
किया गया है। तो इसमें मलिशियस फ्लैग हमें
करने के लिए मलिशियस फ्लैग चेक करना
पड़ेगा। रिपोर्ट्स पर एक बार देख लेते
हैं। इसमें देख लेते हैं। मलिशस फ्लैग
मलेशियस एक्टिविटी यह रही
दिस वन
यह है अ
pब mark.com mark.com जो है मलेशियस का
फ्लैग है यहां पे। एक mark.com है। ठीक
है? एंड दिस इज़ द प्रोसेस।
यह तो उसका पीडीएफ का है। ठीक है? यह कौन
सा है? मार्क ये तो ब्राउजिंग का है। चलो
और कौन सी है? माइक्रोल html ठीक है। अटैक
चेन exc टेरर पीडीएफ ठीक है। ये सारे हैं।
नहीं नहीं दिस इज़ वन द इसको हम एक सेकंड
के लिए यहां पे अ
इसको हम बैक कर लेते हैं एक बार। जस्ट अ
सेकंड।
जस्ट अ जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइज़। जस्ट अ सेकंड।
इसको हम यहां से निकालते हैं। क्या है
हिंट में यहां पे?
कनेक्शंस में तो है बट हमारे कनेक्शंस में
इसका कुछ वर्डिक्ट आ नहीं रहा है ना।
दिक्कत यही है कि हमारे कनेक्शंस में
एक्रोड डेड रीडर का कुछ वर्डिक्ट आ नहीं
रहा है। सो लेट्स सी।
स्टार्ट्स इंटरनेट एक्सप्लोरर। यह इंटरनेट
एक्सप्लोरर को स्टार्ट करता है। अच्छी बात
है। बट हमारे कनेक्शंस में इट्स नॉट
कमिंग।
मलिशस एक्टिविटी यहां पे होनी चाहिए। यहां
पे शो करनी चाहिए। मलिसिस एक्टिविटी क्या
है? बट यह शो नहीं कर रहा है।
आकामाई है। ओके ओके ओके ओके
ओके
256 वाइट।
ओके। यहां पे मलिशस एक्टिविटी कनेक्शंस
में शो होते हैं। बट आई थिंक इनका कुछ इशू
है। शायद ये नहीं हो रहा है अभी। बट यहां
पे इनको करना चाहिए। यहां पे डायरेक्ट
यहां पे मलिश एक्टिविटी शो होनी चाहिए।
जैसे मैं यहां पे अगर एक्यूरेटर आरडी 2808
पे करूं कनेक्शंस पे यहां पे ही चल लेते
हैं। लेट्स सी यहां पे अगर दिखाता है कि
नहीं अ
नहीं यहां पे भी
दिस वन इज़
ओके सो इट्स नॉट शोइंग एक्सक्टली तो मैं
यहां पे अगर नॉर्मली इसको भी करूं और इसको
चेक करूं बट सस्िशियस है। ठीक है? बट
एक्सजेक्टली इट्स नॉट शोइंग वो यहां पे
दिखाता है मेलसियस एक्टिविटी है। अह
नहीं मलिशियस एक्टिविटी दिखाता है। यहां
पे कनेक्शंस में जो दिख रहा है ना यहां पे
कनेक्शंस में। तो यहां पे ये मलिशियस
दिखाएगा। बट यहां पे शायद अभी नहीं शो कर
रहा है। आई डोंट नो व्हाई इट इज़ नॉट
शोइंग। बिकॉज़ आंसर यही होना चाहिए। जो
आंसर मैंने यहां पर किया है, यह आंसर ही
होना चाहिए। एक बार चेक करते हैं। ओके,
सही है। आंसर सही है। आंसर सही है। यही
है। वही आई वास थिंकिंग कि व्हाई इट इज़
शोइंग इनकरेक्ट। सो, इट इज़ करेक्ट। सो,
आंसर इज़ वही है। 26 यही है मेलिसिस
एक्टिविटी जो आईपी है आपकी 26, 1072 जो
मैंने पहले बोला था। शायद पता नहीं कुछ
होगा इनका। ट्राईक के साइड से भी इनके
अलग-अलग नाटक होते रहते हैं। कभी कुछ होता
है, कभी कुछ होता है। तो इट वाज़ गुड।
फाइनली वी फाउंड द आईपी एड्रेस। ठीक है?
कंटिन्यू इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग द टेक्स्ट
रिपोर्ट व्हिच विंडज़ प्रोसेस इज़ क्लाज़्ड
ऐज़ पोटेंशियली बैड ट्रैफिक। अब यहां पे
टेक्स्ट रिपोर्ट को एनालिसिस करना है। और
कौन सा Windows प्रोसेस जो है पोटेंशियल
बैड ट्रैफिक है। ठीक है? तो हम देख लेते
हैं पोटेंशियल बैड ट्रैफिक कौन सा Windows
प्रोसेस है भाई?
पोटेंशियली बैड ट्रैफिक। Windows प्रोसेस
की बात यहां पे हो रही है। ठीक है? तो हम
यहां पे Windows प्रोसेस की बात करें अगर
तो ये जरूरी नहीं है कि यही प्रोसेस होगा।
मैं बैक करता हूं। मैं डायरेक्ट पेमेंट
अपडेट वाली उस पे चलता हूं। अरे सॉरी
सॉरी।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़][गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? अब यहां पे प्रोसेससेस नेटवर्क
थ्रेट्स में डालते हैं। पोटेंशियली बैड
ट्रैफिक। ये रही पोटेंशियल बैड ट्रैफिक।
आप यहां पे आएंगे नेटवर्क थ्रेट्स में। तो
यहां पे आएगा एसबीसी होस्ट.ex। यह एक
नेटवर्क पोटेंशियली बैड ट्रैफिक है। तो
इसको हम यहां पे डाल देते हैं, चेक कर
लेते हैं। दैट्स इट। डन। हो गया।
हम डन हो गया सिंपल। अब यहां पे है एक्सेल
एग्जीक्यूटेबल। इसको मैं फिलहाल के लिए
यहां पे शायद बंद ओके देख लेते हैं क्या
है। इन दिस टास्क ही विल कंटिन्यू
इन्वेस्टिगेशन यूजिंग एनी रन फोकसिंग ऑन अ
डिफरेंट सैंड बॉक्स एनालिसिस ऑफ अ
सस्पेक्टेड फिशिंग अटैचमेंट रिव्यू द ये
एक अलग ही फिशिंग अटैचमेंट है। तो इसको
फिलहाल के लिए मैं अ
क्लोज कर देता हूं। ठीक है? सैंडbक्स
एनालिसिस यहां पर है। इसको भी हम यहां से
क्लोज कर देते हैं। इट्स नॉट रिक्वायर्ड
एनी मोर। राइट?
यहां इसको ओपन कर लेते हैं एनी रन से। ठीक
है? अब यहां पे सेंड बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट में
एक एक्सेल फाइल है आपके पास। रिव्यू द
एग्जीक्यूशन रिजल्ट्स टू आइडेंटिफाई
नोटेबल बिहेवियर्स इंक्लूडिंग प्रोसेस
एक्टिविटी, नेटवर्क कनेक्शन। सब अब रिव्यू
कीजिए। अब यहां पे आप बताइए इसका क्या है?
हाउ डज़ द एन क्लासिफाई द अटैचमेंट? तो,
यहां पे मेलेसियस एक्टिविटी। वहां पे
सस्पिस एक्टिविटी था। यहां पे मेलेसियस
एक्टिविटी आइडेंटिफाई कर रहा है। कर दिया
हमने। व्हाट इज़ द फाइल नेम ऑफ़ द एक्सेल
अटैचमेंट? बहुत सिंपल है। ये रहा हमारा
फाइल नेम। हमने इसको कॉपी पेस्ट कर दिया।
अबे ये क्या कॉपी कर लिया मैंने? इसको
कॉपी कर लिया ना? कॉपी सीबी ये क्या आ रहा
है भाई? मैं तो इसको स्कैन मैं तो इसको
कॉपी कर रहा हूं। ये ओपन किसी और कॉपी के
हो रहा है। हां।
तो ये हमने कॉपी कर लिया। यहां से फाइल
नेम नॉर्मल सा फाइल नेम है। इसको हमने
कॉपी कर लिया। इन्वेस्टिगेट द एक्सेल
अटैचमेंट। एक्सेल अटैचमेंट को
इन्वेस्टिगेट कीजिए। व्हाट इज़ द एसए 256#श
वैल्यू? फिर से वही चीज़ है। एसए 256 हैश
वैल्यू निकालना है। तो यहां से हमने कॉपी
किया एसए 256 हैश वैल्यू। यहां पे हमने
पेस्ट किया। दैट्स इट। हो गया। व्हाट आईपी
एड्रेस इज़ एसोसिएटेड वि द मशियस डोमेन bz
9 holdings.com? B 9 holdings.com
मैिलिसिस डोमेन है। इससे कौन सा आईपी
एड्रेस एसोसिएटेड है? चलिए ठीक है। तो हम
एक काम करते हैं कनेक्शंस में bिन
होल्डिंग देखते हैं भाई कौन सा है b9 तो
यह रहा bis 9 डोमेन bिनइन हो holdings.com
इससे एसोसिएटेड आईपी एड्रेस ये हमारा है
तो इसको कॉपी कर लेते हैं bin holding.com
को हमने यहां पे पेस्ट कर दिया।
ठीक है? व्हिच अदर डोमेन इज़ क्लासिफाइड एज़
मलेशियस? तो यहां पे फिर से नेटवर्क थेश
में चलते हैं। कौन सा अदर डोमेन
क्लासिफाइड है? अह ऐज़ अह क्या ऐज़ अ क्या
क्लासिफ़िकेशन है भाई? मलेशियस। तो मलेशियस
नेटवर्क ट्रोजन वाज़ डिटेक्टेड तो अदर
डोमेन यही है भाई ईक्यू नेट 2.ex नहीं
नहीं डोमेन पूछ रहे हैं ना ये तो कौन सा
है भाई अ यहां पे डीएनएस
ईक्यू नेट 32.ex ठीक है कनेक्शन चलते हैं
बिज़ होल्डिंग है
एचटीपी रिक्वेस्ट पे चलते
तो यहां पर दूसरा कौन सा है भाई? यहां पर
ईक्यू नेट 32 वाला है जो मलेशियस यहां पर
आपका नेम नेटवर्क थ्रेड्स में आप जाएंगे
तो यहां पे देखेंगे कि एक नेटवर्क थ्रोजन
है तो मलेशियस यही है। तो क्या है ये? EQ
नेट 32.exc ये वाली फाइल है आपकी। ठीक है?
ये वाली ये वाली प्रोसेस है। 100 आउट ऑफ़
100 यहां पे आ रहा है। आप इसकी डिटेल्स
यहां पे आप चेक आउट करेंगे। मोर इनफो पे
जाएंगे तो आप चलिए मोर इनफो पे चलते हैं
यहां पे। तो यहां पे बोलना है व्हा अदर
डोमेन क्लासिफाइड इससे रिलेटेड डोमेन कौन
सा है भाई? डोमेन देख लेते हैं अपन
एचtडीपी रिक्वेस्ट में देखते हैं डोमेन
क्या है? बिज 9 होल्डिंग तो एक है ही अ
दिस डोमेन
फाइंड रिजल्ट्स डॉट साइट फाइंड रिजल्ट डॉट
साइट ये डोमेन है।
फाइंड रिजल्ट डॉट साइट इसको देख लेते हैं।
ठीक है? करेक्ट। यह भी यह है। मतलब
मलिशियस था। व्हाट वनेबिलिटी डस दिस
मलेशियस अटैचमेंट अटेमप्ट्स टू एक्सप्लइट?
कौन सा वनेबिलिटी एक्सप्लइट करने की कोशिश
कर रहा है भाई? ये देखना हमें ये मजा
आएगा। कौन सा वनेबिलिटी है यार?
तो ये अटैचमेंट है।
अब इसकी वलेबिलिटी कौन सी है जो
यूज़ में ली जा रही है। मतलब जिसको
एक्सप्लइट करने की कोशिश की जा रही है। सो
लेट्स सी। तो ये जो है सीवी 2017 11882 को
एक्सप्लइट करने की कोशिश कर रहा है। सीवी
तो इसको हम कर देते हैं। सीवी वाली जो है
ओके ये एक ये हट जा होगा 11 1 टू है लास्ट
में यहां पे टू कर देते हैं। ये सीवी इसको
एक्सप्लइट करने जा रहे हैं। ये वाले
एबिलिटी है। सीवी 2017 का कोई है उससे
रिलेटेड। ठीक है? तो ये हमारा हो गया।
दैट्स इट। कंक्लूजन में तो कुछ आई थिंक
होगा नहीं तो दैट्स इट। हो गया। डन। सो इट
[संगीत] वाज़ फिशिंग एनालिसिस। फिशिंग
टूल्स जो हम हमने अभी देखा यहां पे
एनालिसिस करके हमने सारा कुछ देखा। ए टू
जेड चीजें करी एंड वी कंप्लीटेड इट। राइट?
सो इट वाज़ इंटरेस्टिंग। प्रीमियम रूम था।
काफी मजा आया। काफी इंटरेस्टिंग लगा। काफी
आपको सीखने को आज या जानने को जरूर मिला
होगा इस रूम के थ्रू में। मैं ऐसा मानता
हूं। एंड इट वाज़ वेरी वेरी वेरी वेरीेंट।
ठीक है? फेसिंग एनालिसिस में यह बहुत
एनालिसिस टूल्स का जो रूम था बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट था। अब एक रूम और है फिशिंग
प्रिवेंशन का। मैं आपको इसका ओवरव्यू जरूर
दूंगा। सब कुछ आपको बताऊंगा यहां पे
फिशिंग प्रिवेंशन में। काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
है। अब इंटरेस्टिंग है तो मैं आपको थोड़ा
सा इसके बारे में बता देता हूं। अभी ये
देखो ये अ थ्योरेटिक थोड़ा सा वैसे है।
एसपीएफ वगैरह डीकेआईएम के बारे में आपको
जानकारी यहां पे मिलने वाली है। बट काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग भी है। ठीक है? इसको हम
स्टार्ट करेंगे। जस्ट वेट फॉर 2 मिनट्स।
[खांसने की आवाज़]
हां
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अ बा
ओके बदन शाह हेलो सर आई एम एसोसिएट
एनालिस्ट एल वन करेंटली आई एम इन क्लास 24
एंड दिस इज़ माय फर्स्ट लाइव क्लास यू आर
डूइंग अ ग्रेट जॉब आई लव योर कोर्स एंड द
वे यू टीच लव एंड रिस्पेक्ट फ्रॉम
बांग्लादेश दैट्स ग्रेट ब्रदर एंड क्लेम
ग्लड दैट यू आर लविंग एंड एंड लाइकिंग द
ट्रेनिंग, कीप स्टडिंग एंड कीप लर्निंग
मजे करते रहिए आप। मस्त कंटेंट तो आपको
मिलता ही रहेगा। ठीक है? चलिए आई हैड फॉन
टुडे। थैंक यू वेरी मच। कल आ रही है भाई।
कल आ रही है। टुमारो।
कल आ रही है।
ठीक है। चलिए। सो
ओके। लेट्स स्टार्ट दिस। ओके चलिए यहां पर
मैं आपको ओवरव्यू देता चलूंगा।
इंट्रोडक्शन है यहां पे। तो मैंने पहले ही
बोला था कि आपको कुछ टर्म्स हैं। एसपीएफ,
डीकेएम, डीएमए आरसी, एसएम, एसएमआई या
एसएमआईएमई ये सब हम जानेंगे देखेंगे। सो
बेसिकली यहां पे एक टर्म है एसपीएफ
सेंडर्स पॉलिसी फ्रेमवर्क। ये क्या होता
है? एग्जैक्टली आप इसको थोड़ा सा जान
लीजिए। ये ज्यादा टाइम इसमें नहीं लगेगा।
इस वाले पार्ट में हम थोड़ा वो करेंगे।
ठीक है?
सेंडर्स फॉर पॉलिसी फ्रेमवर्क जो है ये
डीमार्सियन अ प्लेटफार्म डेडिकेटेड टू
हेल्पिंग ऑनेशन प्रोटेक्ट ईमेल डोमेनस
फ्रॉम फिशिंग डिफाइन द सेंटर इन्होंने
डीमार्शियन ने कि फिशिंग ईमेल्स से बचाया
जा सके ईमेल्स जो डोमेन ईमेल होते हैं
उनको सेफ गार्ड किया जा सके डोमेन ईमेल का
मतलब क्या होता है सिंपल जैसे कि मान लो
मेरा डिफ्रronics.com वेबसाइट है तो अब
dfonic.com का जो डिफ़्रॉनिक्स रिलेटेड जो
डोमेन होंगे जैसे कि su@ dfonic.com ये तो
डोमेन मेल हो गया है ना@f.com
हेलो.com info@.com
राइट hr@f.com
ऐसे तो ये डोमेन मेल है। तो इनकी
सिक्योरिटी के लिए स्पेशली एसपीएफ को मतलब
डिजाइन किया गया। सेंडर्स पॉलिसी
फ्रेमवर्क इज़ यूज्ड टू ऑथेंटिकेट द सेंडर
ऑफ़ इनेबल। तो मतलब ईमेल के सेंडर को
ऑथेंटिकेट करता है। जैसे आप अगर से मेल
सेंड कर रहे हो किसी को तो आपके उस
सेंडिंग मेल को ऑथेंटिकेट करने का काम
एसपीएफ के तरफ से होता है। विथ एन एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड इन प्लेस इंटरनेट
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर्स कैन वेरीफाई दैट अ मेल सर्वर
इज़ ऑथराइज़्ड टू सेंड ईमेल फॉर अ स्पेसिफिक
डोमेन। मतलब कि मेल सर्वर जो है एक
स्पेसिफिक डोमेन से ईमेल भेजने के लिए
ऑथराइज़्ड है। यह एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड बताता है।
एन एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड इज़ अ डीएनएस टीxटी
रिकॉर्ड। यह एक डीएनएस टीxटी रिकॉर्ड है
जिसमें IPपी एड्रेसेस होता है जो कि अलाउड
होते हैं मेल को सेंड करने के लिए आपके
डोमेन के बिहाफ में। इस तरीके से यह पूरा
जो है काम करता है। चलिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब यहां पे
मैं इसको थोड़ा सा एक्सपेंड कर देता हूं।
अरे भाई हो जा यार
हम
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] कुछ इस तरीके
से। अब यहां पे किस तरीके से होता है? आप
एज अ सेंडर होते हैं, मेल सेंड करते हैं।
यह एक जाता है सेंडिंग ऑर्गेनाइजेशन का जो
ईमेल सर्वर है, जो भी सेंड कर रहा है मेल
उस ऑ्गेनाइजेशन के ईमेल सर्वर के पास ईमेल
को ट्रांसफर किया जाता है। यह रिसिपिएंट
जो जहां पे आप पेमेंट भेज रहे हो उसका
ईमेल सर्वर है वहां तक जाती है। ठीक है?
अब यह क्या करता है? सेंडिंग ऑग्स डीएनएस
सर्वर के पास जाता है। ठीक है? एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड पब्लिश होती है वहां पे। वहां से
डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड्स लेकर आता है। एंड सेंडर
आईडी फ्रेमवर्क जो होता है एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड
लुकअप करता है और वह डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड्स
लेकर आ जाता है। उसके बाद अगर वो एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड में सब कुछ सही है तो यह
ऑथेंटिकेट हो जाता है। रेपुटेशन डेटाबेस
से चेक होते हुए यह ईमेल रिसीपिंट के
बॉक्स में पहुंच जाता है। और अगर
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] नहीं होता है
ऑथेंटिकेशन तो यह रिजेक्ट हो जाता है। यह
पूरी की पूरी प्रोसेस होती है। सिंपल। अब
एसपीएफ में कुछ वेरिफिकेशन रिजल्ट्स होते
हैं। जैसे कि एक होता है पास
न्यूट्रल नन। तो इसका मतलब है जब भी ऐसा
हो नन हो जो जब एसपीएफ चेक होता है उसमें
रिजल्ट्स में अगर नन आए न्यूट्रल आए या
पास आए तो इसका मतलब है एक्सेप्ट कर लो।
अलऊ करो मेल को मेल ओके चलेगा। अब एसपीएफ
रिजल्ट्स को जो है एसपीएफ किटरमैन मैं चेक
करता हूं। यह एक वेबसाइट है। एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड टेस्टिंग के लिए वेबसाइट है। आप
इसमें एसपीएफ का देख सकते हो। जैसे मैंने
अगर यहां पे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स.com डाला तो मैं
इसका एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड देखूंगा। तो इट विल
शो द एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड ऑफ़ dfonic.com। ठीक
है? तो यहां पे मैंने किया। अब इट विल
ट्राई टू गिव द रिकॉर्ड। लेट्स सी। या और
भी वेबसाइट्स हैं। बहुत सारी वेबसाइट्स
हैं। कोई एक नहीं काम करे दूसरा यूज़ कर
लो। MX टूलबॉक्स करके भी है। वह भी आपको
देगा। आई थिंक इट्स नॉट वर्किंग। लेट्स
सी। हां, इनका ओके। इनका कुछ इशू है। इट्स
नॉट वर्किंग। तो चलिए MX टूलबॉक्स है।
आप इसको भी यूज कर सकते हैं। दिस इज आल्सो
टूल। यहां पर आप आएंगे तो यहां पे आपको
एसपीएफ लुकअप आएगा। यहां पे कहीं पे देखने
को मिल जाएगा। एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड लुक। आप
इसमें भी अपना डोमेन डाल दीजिए जिनका एस
जिनका एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड चेक करना है कि
अवेलेबल है या नहीं है। तो आप देखेंगे
यहां पे कि अवेलेबल डिफ्रॉनिक्स के लिए
एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड जो है वो अवेलेबल है। एंड
यू कैन सी हियर कि ये एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड यहां
पे काम कर रहा है। तो इट्स मतलब मतलब कि
इट्स ओके ये आपका अ फाइन है। अगर एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड आपके डोमेन के लिए है। अगर यहां
नहीं होता तो कुछ भी नहीं होता।
अगर रिजल्ट्स [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
में सॉफ्ट टेल सॉरी सॉफ्ट फेल या पर्म एरर
करके ऐसा कुछ लिखा आ रहा है तो यह फ्लैग्ड
है मलेशियस या सस्िशियस हो सकता है फेल या
टेंप एरर आ रहा है मतलब कि इसको रिजेक्ट
करो इसको तो बिल्कुल ही नहीं डिलीवर करना
है यह भी एक तरीका होता है कोई बात नहीं
स्वामी जी नो इशूज़ तो एसपी रिकॉर्ड में
कुछ इस तरीके की फील्ड होती हैं जैसा आप
यहां पे देख रहे हो कुछ इस तरीके से यहां
डिफ्रॉिस का भी हमने देखा तो हमें यहां पे
कुछ ऐसा ही फ़ील्ड देखने को यहां पे मिला
है। तो यहां पे सबसे पहला फील्ड होता है
वर्जन। एसपीएफ का वर्जन होता है द स्टार्ट
ऑफ द एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड जो कि वर्जन दिखाता
है एसपीएफ वन। उसके बाद होती है आईपी
एड्रेस। द आईपी जो कि मेल सेंड कर सकता है
वो आईपी एड्रेस होती है। इंक्लूड मतलब कि
व्हिच डोमेनस कैन सेंड मेल। अब इसमें
इंक्लूड में सारे डोमेनस जो मेल को सेंड
कर सकते हैं वो इंक्लूड होते हैं। एंड हफन
ऑल नॉन ऑथराइड ईमेल्स विल बी रिजेक्ट। हफन
ऑल का मतलब होता है जितने भी नॉन ऑथराइज़्ड
ईमेल्स हैं उसको रिजेक्ट कर दिया जाएगा।
कुछ इस तरीके से यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
ये एक इस तरीके की चीजें होती हैं। ठीक
है?
फील्स होती है। ठीक है? इसमें भी अब हफन
होता है। एक ऐसे एक सिल एक और सिंबल होती
है। वो मल्टीपल चीजें होती है। बट यहां पे
सिंपली यहां पे अ छोड़ते हैं। यहां पे
टूल्स पे आते हैं। द
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एसपीएफ
सर्वेयर टूल एक और टूल है। जैसे मैंने
किडरमैन बताया मैंने mx टूलबॉक्स में वैसे
ही एसपीएफ सर्वेयर जो है वो भी एक टूल है।
इसको इसमें भी आप जैसे डोमेन डालेंगे
dfonic.com
तो आपको सारे रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे। हाईफाई
यूएसपी ऑफ़ रिकॉर्ड इज़ वैलिड बट अब यहां पे
आ रहा है कि
डीएमसी एंड अकाउंट नहीं है। यह सब नहीं
है। ये इनका अपना है। लेकिन हां वैलिड है
ये। तो इट्स गुड। यहां पे सारी जो लाइक
व्हाटएवर डिटेल्स आर देयर। ये डिटेल्स
आपको यहां पे सारी दे देंगे। पूरी रॉ
अच्छी खासी डिटेल। ठीक है? तो जैसे ही
ट्राईक का इन्होंने किया तो ट्राईक के भी
एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड्स कुछ इस तरीके से आए हैं।
एंड यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं यह रिजल्ट्स
आ रहे हैं। spएफ Google, ईमेल,
चार्जb.com. ठीक है? उसी तरीके से Google
एडमिन टूलबॉक्स का मैसेज हेडर जो है वो भी
डिलीवरी डिटेल्स की ईमेल की फुल हेडर्स
यहां से निकाल के दे जैसे ईमेल हेडर
डालेंगे ना तो आपको एसपीएफ के रिजल्ट ये
दिखा देता है एसपीएफ पास फेल क्या है वो
भी दिखा देता है सब कुछ बेस्ड ऑन द अभी
आते हैं इसके लैब पे बेस्ड ऑन द ट्राई
हैकस एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड अबव हाउ मेनी डोमेनस
आर ऑथराइज्ड टू सेंड मेल ऑन इट्स बिहाफ
कितने डोमेन सेंड करने के लिए इसके डोमेन
के हिसाब से है तो एसपीएफ रिकॉर्ड यह रहा
ट्राईकमी का तो कितने डोमेन है मुझे बताइए
जो अलाउड है मेल भेजने के लिए इनके स्पेफ
रिकॉर्ड के मुकाब के मुकाब मतलब के
अकॉर्डिंग बता दीजिए
हाउ मेनी मेल्स आर हाउ मेनी डोमेनस आर
ऑथराइज्ड
प्लीज टेल मी एवरीबडी
सभी [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] लोग बताइए
आई वांट टू नो कि आप में से कितने लोगों
को क्या लगता है?
प्लीज बताइए सभी।
किसी ने एक ने बोला है तीन एक ने सात एक
ने तीन तीन पांच टू मोर पीपल प्लीज फाइव
थ्री
ओके मोर आंसर्स आई एम वेटिंग फॉर मोर
आंसर्स इतने लोग हैं यार बट आंसर इतने कम
क्यों कर रहे हो आंसर करो आंसर आंसर तो
करो। देखो जिन लोगों ने भी सात बोला है,
एक बंदे ने बोला है बस वो उनका आंसर रॉन्ग
है। जिन्होंने पांच बोला है उनका भी आंसर
रॉन्ग है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यहां पे यार तीन ही तो हैं। देखो ना कैसे
पांच कैसे हैं? एक है google.com
एक है चार्जb.com एक है hubpotmail.net
तीन ही तो डोमेन है। यही तो डोमेन कहलाते
हैं ना। तो पांच और सात कैसे हो सकते हैं?
सो थ्री इट्स थ्री।
फाइन। [संगीत]
व्हाट इज द इंटेंडेंट एक्शन ऑफ एन ईमेल
दैट रिटर्न्स अ सॉफ्ट फेल वेरिफिकेशन
रिजल्ट? तो सॉफ्ट फेल वेरिफिकेशन रिजल्ट
का इंटेंडेंट एक्शन क्या होता है? फ्लैग्ड
होता है। वो फ्लैग होता है। मतलब वैसे
ईमेल को फ्लैग कर देना है। मलेशियस या
जैसे भी हो तो फ्लैग होगा। हो गया। राइट?
डन। अब यहां पे इसका नेक्स्ट है डीके
आईएम। डीके आईएम क्या होता है? डोमेन कीज़
आइडेंटिफाइड मेल। इसका फुल फॉर्म होता है
डीकेआईएम। यह भी एक टीएक्सटी रिकॉर्ड होता
है आपके डीएनएस के अंदर। जैसे एसपीएफ
रिकॉर्ड होते हैं ना वैसे ही यह भी एक
टीएक्सटी रिकॉर्ड होता है। यह भी एक तरीके
का मतलब कि ऑथेंटिकेशन का काम करता है।
ठीक है? जो भी आप ईमेल भेज रहे हैं। तो
डीए के आईएम स्टैंड्स फॉर डोमेन के
आइडेंटिफाइड मेल एंड इज़ यूज्ड फॉर
ऑथेंटिकेशन ऑफ़ एन ईमेल दैट्स बीइंग सेंट।
जो ईमेल सेंड हो रही है उसका ऑथेंटिकेशन
में के लिए यह रिस्पांसिबल होता है। लाइक
एसपीएफ एसपीएफ की तरह ही डीकेआईएम इज़ एन
ओपन स्टैंडर्ड फॉर ईमेल ऑथेंटिकेशन दैट इज़
यूज़्ड फॉर डीएमएआरसी एलाइनमेंट। डीकेआईएम
के अलावा एक डीएमएआरसी भी होता है। उसी के
लाइक एलाइनमेंट के लिए इसको यूज़ किया जाता
है। अ डीकेआईएम रिकॉर्ड एकज़िस्ट इन द
डीएनएस बट इट इज़ मोर कॉम्प्लेक्स दैन
एसपीएफ। डीकेआईएम होता है बट यह
कॉम्प्लेक्स है थोड़ा। डीके आईएम्स
एडवांटेज इज दैट इट कैन सर्वाइव
फॉरवर्डिंग व्हिच मेक्स इट सुपीरियर टू
एसपीएफ एंड अ फाउंडेशन फॉर सिक्योरिटी
सिक्योरिंग योर ईमेल मतलब ये फॉरवर्डिंग
भी जो है ना उसको भी ध्यान में रखता है जो
आप ईमेल्स को फॉरवर्ड करते हो ना तो उसको
भी यह चेक करेगा वेरीफाई करता है
ऑथेंटिकेट करता है तो कुछ इस तरीके से ये
काम करती है कुछ
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] इस तरीके से
ये मतलब काम करती है तो ये पब्लिक पब्लिश
करती है पब्लिक की डीकेएम की इस पे अभी
ज्यादा फोकस मत कीजिएगा आपके लिए उतना
मतलब ये आप कॉम्प्लेक्स हो जाएगा आपको
लगेगा कि क्या ही है नॉर्मल सा है। यह एक
पब्लिक की होता है। एक प्राइवेट डीकम साइन
की होता है। डीएनएस सर्वर के थ्रू होते
हुए पब्लिक की रिट्राइव होके और ईमेल
सर्वर के होते हुए प्राइवेट की से मैच
करते हुए और रिसिपिएंट के मेल तक पहुंच
जाती है। यह सिंपल सा प्रोसेस है। बट इस
पे आपको ज्यादा ध्यान नहीं देना है
क्योंकि ये आपके लिए उतना रिलेटेबल नहीं
है। आपके लिए जरूरी नहीं है। राइट?
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
लेट्स इसको ब्रेकडाउन करके मैं थोड़ा सा
बता देता हूं। वैसे उतना इंपॉर्टेंट नहीं
है। व्हेन एन ईमेल इज़ सेंट द सेंडिंग मेल
सर्वर यूज़ज़ अ प्राइवेट की। सेंडिंग मेल
सर्वर क्या करता है? प्राइवेट की को यूज़
करता है। टू ऐड अ डिजिटल सिग्नेचर टू द
ईमेल। ईमेल के लिए एक डिजिटल सिग्नेचर
बनाता है। एक ऑथेंटिकेशन बनाता है
प्राइवेट की का यूज़ करके। द रिसीविंग
सर्वर रिट्रीव्स द पब्लिक की फ्रॉम डोमेनस
डीकेआईएम रिकॉर्ड। अब जो रिसीविंग सर्वर
है, वह डोमेन का जो डीकेआईएम रिकॉर्ड होता
है ना जो डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड में डला हुआ होता
है, वहां से वह क्या करता है? पब्लिक की
को उठाता है।
टू वेरीफाई द मैसेज ट्रूली कम फ्रॉम द
डोमेन। इस चीज को वेरीफाई करने के लिए ये
मैसेज सच में डोमेन से ही आया है। इफ द
सिग्नेचर मैच अगर यह पब्लिक की प्राइवेट
की से मैच कर जाती है, द ईमेल इज़ ऑथेंटिक।
तो ईमेल जो है ऑथेंटिक कहलाएगा। अदरवाइज़
यह फ्लैग या रिजेक्ट हो सकती है। दैट्स
इट। राइट। हेलो ब्रदर। हेलो एलरीन। अब आते
हैं डीकेआईएम रिकॉर्ड्स पे। नाउ वी आर
कमिंग फॉर द डीकेएम रिकॉर्ड्स। सैंपल
डीकेएम रिकॉर्ड्स कुछ इस तरीके से होता
है। कुछ ऐसा इसमें क्या होता है? वर्जन
होता है डीकेएम का जहां से स्टार्ट होता
है। यह तो यह वर्जन है डीके वन। उसके बाद
आता है के यह होता है आपका की का टाइप।
कौन सा इंक्रिप्शन यूज़ हो रहा है? तो
आरएसए इंक्रिप्शन एल्गोरिदम इज़ अ
स्टैंडर्ड जो नॉर्मली स्टैंडर्ड एक
एल्गोरिदम आरएसए का है आपका तो वो यूज़ हो
रहा है। पी पी जो है इज़ द पब्लिक की दैट
विल बी मैच्ड टू द प्राइवेट की टू वेरीफाई
द डीकम सिग्नेचर। तो पी के जगह यहां पे
पब्लिक की होती है जो कि प्राइवेट की से
मैच की जाती है। वही प्राइ वही प्राइवेट
की जो यहां पे ऐड की जाती है सेंडिंग मेल
से जो आपको जो सेंडिंग मेल सर्वर है जो
प्राइवेट की जो है अ यूज़ करती है उससे मैच
करती है। ठीक है? बस सिंपल। ओके? तो कुछ
इस तरीके से आप देख सकते हैं। अ कुछ इस
तरीके से यहां पे डिटेल्स वगैरह आती हैं।
यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं। डीके आईएम इक्वल
टू पर्म एरर आ रहा है। नो की फॉर
सिग्नेचर। सिग्नेचर के लिए कोई की नहीं
है। कुछ इस तरीके का आता है सामने।
हालांकि इन चीजों का जो है अ जो अ नॉलेज
है आपको एक बेसिक नॉलेज चाहिए एज एन एसओसी
L1 एज एन एसओसी L1 की मैं बात कर रहा हूं।
आपको बेसिक नॉलेज ही चाहिए। बहुत ज्यादा
डीप आपको घुसने की जरूरत इसमें अभी फिलहाल
नहीं पड़ेगा आपको जब तक आप L2 L3 नहीं
बनते। ठीक है? तो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे
क्वेश्चन है बेस्ड ऑन द सैंपल हेडर अबव
व्हाट इज द रीज़ फॉर पम एरर? मतलब पम एरर
का रीज़न क्या है भाई? तो सिंपल पोम एरर का
रीज़न है नो की फॉर सिग्नेचर। यही रीज़न है
तो कर दो नो की फॉर सिग्नेचर। नो की फॉर
सिग्नेचर। दैट्स इट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
आई थिंक सही है। सही है। [संगीत] बिल्कुल
सही है। आपको आप लोगों को गाइस समझ में आ
रहा है यहां तक? आर यू गेटिंग गाइस? लेट
मी नो।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अंडरस्टुड
ठीक है।
ठीक है? बहुत बढ़िया। अब आते हैं
डीएमएआरसी। डीएमआरसी का भी सेम वही है। यह
भी एक तरह का लाइक स्टैंडर्ड है। मैं
जिसको बोलते हैं डोमेन बेस्ड मैसेज
ऑथेंटिकेशन रिपोर्टिंग एंड कंफर्मस।
ठीक है? इसका मतलब क्या होता है? डीएमआरसी
एक ओपन सोर्स स्टैंडर्ड है। ठीक है?
यूज्ड यूज अ कांसेप्ट कॉल्ड एलाइनमेंट टू
टाई द रिजल्ट ऑफ टू अदर ओपन सोर्स
स्टैंडर्ड्स एसपीएफ एंड डीकेआईएम ठीक है
टू द कंटेंट ऑफ द ईमेल तो ये दो जो एसपीएफ
और डीकेआईएम है इनके जो रिजल्ट्स हैं उनसे
टाई करने का एक अलाइनमेंट एक कांसेप्ट है
जो उनसे टाई करने का एक अलाइनमेंट है जो
मतलब बेसिकली अभी करता क्या है अभी पता चल
जाएगा। दिस मींस दैट डीएमआरसी इंश्यर्स द
सेंडर्स डोमेन मैचेस द डोमेनस वेरीिफाइड
बाय एसएफ एंड डीकेआईएम। यह एक मेक श्योर
करता है कि जो सेंडर्स का डोमेन है वो उस
डोमेन से मैच करता है जो वेरीफाई किया गया
है एसपीएफ और डीकेआईएम की तरफ से। यानी कि
एसपीएफ ने और जो डीकेआईएम ने वेरीफाई किया
है बेसिकली उससे यह मैच करता है कि भैया
सब सही तो है ना। मतलब ये कंफर्मेशन वाला
एक पार्ट है इसका। ठीक है? एक कंफर्म करता
है कि भ हां सब कुछ सही है ओके है कुछ
गड़बड़ अब तो नहीं है तो भाई ठीक है ओके
इसको चढ़ दो ठीक है
बहुत अच्छी बात है समोजीत बहुत बढ़िया इफ
द अलाइनमेंट फेल्स अगर अलाइनमेंट फेल हो
जाता है कि अगर एसपीएफ और डीकेआईएम ने जो
कंफर्म किया है जो वेरीफाई किया है वो अगर
डीएमएआरसी वेरीफाई नहीं कर पा रही है उसको
कुछ अल्टर लग रहा है तो डीएमए डीएमएआरसी
इंस्ट्रक्ट्स द रिसिपिएंट सर्वर ऑन हाउ टू
हैंडल द ईमेल बेस्ड ऑन द पॉलिसी
स्पेसिफाइड इन द रिजेक्ट तो अब ये जो
रिसिपिएंट होता है जहां पे मेल जा रही है
उसके सर्वर को यह इंस्ट्रक्ट करता है कि
भाई अब इसको कैसे हैंडल करना है क्योंकि
यह तो कुछ गड़बड़ है लोचा है तो इसको अब
कुछ स्पेसिफाइड तरीके से हैंडल आपको करना
है इसमें भी रिकॉर्ड्स होते हैं वर्जन
होता है डीएमआरसी का पी इक्वल टू
क्वारेंटाइन मतलब डीएमआरसी पॉलिसी
क्वारेंटाइन इज़ इक्वल टू इसको आप मूव
स्पैम फोल्डर में कर दीजिए और आर यूए मेल
टू यहां पे फिर उसका जो लाइक एन ऑप्शनल
टैग इन दिस केस एग्रीगेट रिपोर्ट्स विल बी
सेंट टू ईमेल स्पेसिफाइड और एक एक
स्पेसिफिक रिपोर्ट जो है इस ईमेल पे आपको
चला जाएगा। ठीक है? तो अब बेसिकली क्या है
कि जो डीएमआरसी आपके जो आपने देखे होंगे
मेल में आपका जो कभी-कभी आपके मेल आते हैं
तो स्पैम में फोल्डर होता है। एक मेल में
मेल आईडी में स्पैम फोल्डर होता है। Gmail
वगैरह में अभी आप देखते हैं तो कई सारे
मेल जो स्पैम फोल्डर में चले जाते हैं। तो
आपको दिमाग में आता होगा भाई ये इनबॉक्स
में क्यों नहीं है? स्पैम में क्यों चला
गया? क्योंकि वहां पे जो डीएमएआरसी है वो
इंस्ट्रक्ट करता है आपके Gmail को कि भैया
यहां पे ना मैचिंग कुछ गड़बड़ है यहां पे
कुछ तो गड़बड़ है इसको भेज दो स्पैम में
और स्पैम में वो रेपुटेशन नहीं बिल्ड अप
होता हो पाती है उन मेल सर्वर्स की जो
सेंडिंग मेल सर्वर से तो स्पैम में चली
जाती है इसीलिए कोई भी ईमेल अगर स्पैम में
ना जाए इसके लिए पहले उस सेंडिंग मेल
सर्वर जो है जो ईमेल जहां से आ रही है तो
उसके रेपुटेशन डेवलप करनी पड़ती है कि
भैया ज्यादातर लोग उसको अगर बहुत सारे लोग
आप ईमेल भी भेज रहे हो बहुत सारे लोग उस
ईमेल को फ्लैग भी कर देंगे ना वह भी आ
जाएगा फिर स्पैम में ही इनको डीएमआरसी को
लगेगा यह फ्लैग्ड है ज्यादातर लोग इसको
फ्लैग कर रहे हैं सस्िशियस कर रहे हैं तो
इनबॉक्स में डिलीवरी नहीं देंगे तो स्पैम
में जाने का एक ये रीज़न होता है कि
डीएमएआरसी वेरीफाई नहीं कर पाती है उनके
जो कि एसपीएफ और डीके हमने करा है ये चीज
तो एक टूल है डोमेन चेकर करके टूल है अ
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
डीमार्शियन का ही है डोमेन चेककर तो आप
यहां पे आके बेसिकली डेफ़onx.com
कोई भी डोमेन जो है आप उसको एंटर कर सकते
हैं और यह उसके अ बेसिस पे यह आपको
डिटेल्स प्रोवाइड करता है कि इसमें
डीएमआरसी रिकॉर्ड है या नहीं है क्या है।
तो यू हैव अ वैलिड डीएमएआरसी रिकॉर्ड दैट
प्रोवाइड्स विज़िबिलिटी इंटू द एंटायरिटी
ऑफ़ योर ईमेल प्रोग्राम्स। तो मेरे पास एक
डीएमआर जो रिपोर्ट है अह अह यह अवेलेबल है
एसपीएफ भी है डीकेआईएम नहीं है तो डीकेएम
भी डाला जा सकता है वो कोई बड़ी बात नहीं
है तो ये डोमेन चेककर से आपको एग्जैक्टली
पता चल जाता है कि व्हाट इज़ एग्जैक्टली
देयर राइट सो व्हिच डीएमआरसी पॉलिसी
प्रोवाइड्स द ग्रेटेस्ट अमाउंट ऑफ़
प्रोटेक्शन बाय ब्लॉकिंग ईमेल्स दैट फेल
टू डीएमएआरसी चेक तो कौन सा डीएमआरसी
पॉलिसी है भाई जो सबसे ज्यादा वह करता है
अह ब्लॉक करता है भाई तो डीएमआरसी का कौन
कौन सा पॉलिसी है? यह पॉलिसी है। देखो। तो
डीएमआरसी का एक पॉलिसी है।
इन द स्क्रीनशॉट बिलो यू कैन सी दैट
microsoft.com पास्ड ऑल द चेकक्स।
क्लिकिंग द डिटेल्स विल शो यू द एग्जाममिन
द ईच रिकॉर्ड्स एंड पॉलिसी मोर क्लोजली।
एज़ शोन इन द रिकॉर्ड बिलो ऑल ईमेल्स दैट
फेल द डीएमआरसी चेक विल बी रिजेक्टेड
बेस्ड ऑन पी इज़ इक्वल टू रिजेक्ट पॉलिसी
टैग। यह पॉलिसी टैग है जो रिजेक्ट करती
है। तो, हम यहां पे ई इज़ इक्वल टू रिजेक्ट
डाल देंगे। सिंपल
नॉर्मल तो ये डीएमएआरसी था। हालांकि ऐसे
टॉपिक्स जो हैं जैसे कि मैंने आपको जो ये
तीन टॉपिक बताए हैं एसपीएफ, डीकेएम और
डीएमआरसी। इस पे मैं आपसे रिक्वेस्ट
करूंगा कि प्लीज इनके ऊपर थोड़ा रिसर्च
थोड़ा पढ़ लेना, थोड़ी एक्सप्लोर कर लेना।
अ
थोड़ा मतलब थोड़ी अपने से भी एक्सप्लोर
करके थोड़ी पढ़ लेना। ये वैसे भी अच्छे
टॉपिक्स हैं। मतलब गुड गुड टॉपिक्स आपके
नॉलेज के लिए ओवरऑल नॉलेज के लिए भी अच्छा
है। वैसे भी नॉलेज आपकी होनी चाहिए इन
टॉपिक्स के बारे में। ठीक है?
उसके बाद आपके आ जाती हैं एस मेम माइ
सिक्योर या मल्टीपर्पस इंटरनेट मेल
एक्सटेंशंस। तो ये जो है बेसिकली इतना कुछ
खास आपके लिए इंपॉर्टेंट अभी फिलहाल के
लिए नहीं है। इसकी जानकारी के लिए आपको
कुछ खास इंपॉर्टेंट नहीं है। तो मैं इसको
स्किप कर देता हूं क्योंकि ये आप ऐसे ही
है। ये सिक्योर मल्टीपल्स इंटरनेट मेल
एक्सटेंशनंस है। ये एक स्टैंडर्ड
प्रोटोकॉल है फॉर सेंडिंग डिजिटली साइन
एंड इंक्रिप्टेड मैसेजेस। जो डिजिटली साइन
और इंक्रिप्टेड मैसेजेस होते हैं उनके लिए
यह मेनली यूज़ में लिया जाता है। इट इज़
बेस्ड ऑन पब्लिक की क्रिप्टोग्राफी व्हेयर
प्राइवेट की इज़ नेवर शेयरर्ड एंड द पब्लिक
की कैन बी डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड ओपनली। द टू
मेन कॉम्पोनेंट्स सिक्योरिटी फीचर्स ऑफ
एसएमईआर आर एसएमआर डिजिटल सिग्नेचर्स एंड
इंक्रिप्शन। दो तरीके की चीजें यहां पे
इसमें होती है। एक डिजिटल सिग्नेचर होता
है, एक इंक्रिप्शन होता है। ठीक है? तो अब
बेसिकली ये जो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
डिजिटली साइन बहुत सारे मेल्स होते हैं जो
डिजिटली साइन होते हैं और कुछ लोग मेल्स
जो होते हैं वो इंक्रिप्टेड मेल होते हैं।
मैसेजेस होते हैं। राइट? उनके लिए यह
मेनली एस माइ जो है यूज़ में लिया जाता है।
जेने ऐसे मेल के लिए नहीं होता है। जो
इसको क्या करते हैं कि लाइक
उसी को ये सपोर्ट करते हैं। ये प्रोटोकॉल
ऐसा ही प्रोटोकॉल है। तो दो तीन चीजें
होती हैं। डिजिटल सिग्नेचर और एक होता है
इंक्रिप्शन। दो चीजें होती हैं। अब डिजिटल
सिग्नेचर में क्या होता है? क्यों होता
है? द सेंडर साइन द मैसेज विद द प्राइवेट
की। अब सेंडर जो है अपने प्राइवेट की से
उस मैसेज को साइन करता है। राइट? द
रसिपिएंट वेरीफाई द सेंडर्स आइडेंटिटी
यूजिंग द सेंडर्स पब्लिक की। और उस पब्लिक
की से सेंडर के उसे वेरीफाई कर लेता है।
तो इसमें सिक्योरिटी फीचर क्या आती है?
ऑथेंटिकेशन, नॉन रेपुडाइजेशन एंड डाटा
इंटीग्रिटी। ये चीज तीन चीजें आती है। एक
ऑथेंटिकेशन का होता है कि मतलब सेंडर्स
आइडेंटिटी जो है वो कंफर्म है। नॉन
रेपिएशन मतलब कि इंश्योर द सेंडर कैन नॉट
डिनाई सेंडिंग सेंडर ये नहीं बोल सकता कि
नहीं नहीं मैंने नहीं भेजा ये मैसेज ये
मैंने ही भेजा ये पता है डेटा इंटीग्रिटी
कोई भी चेंज तो नहीं हुए रास्ते में। एंड
देन एक इंक्रिप्शन होता है कि सेंडर
इंक्रिप्ट कर देता है मैसेज का रिसिपिएंट
की पब्लिक की से अलाउंग ओनली द रिसीपिंट
टू डिक्रिप विद द प्राइवेट की। अब सेंडर
के पास रिसिपिएंट की पब्लिक की होती है और
रिसिपिएंट के पास सेंडर की पब्लिक की होती
है। उससे मैच करता है ऑोजिट दोनों उल्टा।
ठीक है? अब इसमें इनको कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी
मिलती है। मतलब कॉन्फिडेंट प्राइवेट कीप द
कंटेंट प्राइवेट एंड रीडेबल ओनली टू द
इंटेंडेंट रिसिपिएंट। जिसके लिए बना है।
यह मेल जा रहा है जिसके पास उसी को मिलनी
चाहिए। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सिंपल। यह पूरा प्रोसेस होता है। ठीक है?
इसमें कुछ खास है नहीं। व्हिच एसएमआई
कॉम्पोनेंट एनश्योर दैट ओनली द इंटेंडेंट
रेसिपिएंट कैन रीड द कंटेंट। तो इंटेंडेंट
रेसिपिएंट तो भाई इंक्रिप्शन में ही होती
है। तो इंक्रिप्शन
हालांकि यह कॉन्फ़िडेंशियलिटी होना चाहिए
बट इनके अकॉर्डिंग इंक्रिप्शन है तो
इंक्रिप्शन ही कर लेते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] उसके बाद है
एनालाइजिंग द एसएमटीपी रिस्पॉन्ससेस। अब
हम एसएमटीपी रिस्प्ससेस को यहां पे
एनालाइज़ करेंगे। यह है इंटरेस्टिंग थोड़ा
सा इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है। एसएमटीपी के
रिस्पांस को एनालाइज करेंगे। तो मैं लव
मशीन को स्टार्ट करता हूं यहां पे।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] स्टार्टिंग
अब देखो इन दिस टास्क यू विल एनालाइज़ अ
पीकैप फाइल एक पीकैप फाइल को आप एनालाइज़
करेंगे विथ एसएमटीपी ट्रैफिक सिंपल मेल
ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल ट्रैफिक होगी उसको
एनालाइज़ करेंगे आप सम फ़मिलियरिटी विद द
ठीक है वशार्क का मैं आपको बताऊंगा सब कुछ
जाइए मशीन को स्टार्ट कीजिए और एक फाइल
होगी ट्रैफिक डॉट pcp इसको ओपन कीजिए जो
वायरशार्क में ओपन होगी वायरशार्क एक
ट्रैफिक एनालाइजर या पैकेट एनालाइजर टूल
टूल है नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक एनालाइज कर सकते
हैं आप उसके थ्रू जिसमें कि एक एक्सटेंशन
होती है पी कैप या कैप। यह उनके ट्रैफिक
की फाइल्स जो आप एक्सपोर्ट करते हैं वो
होती है। ठीक है? तो ये आप एनालिसिस कर
सकते हैं। तो हमने यहां पे स्टार्ट कर
दिया है इस मशीन को। अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे हमने
इस पीक एफ फाइल को ओपन कर लिया। कहां गई
भाई?
स्टार्ट हो गया।
ये तो यह वाली हो गई भाई। ये ओपन हो गई
ना।
लेट इट ओपन गाइस।
हां ओपन हो गया। ये ट्रैफिक डॉट पीcap है।
इसको ओपन करेंगे आप तो यह इट विल ओपन इन
वॉश। सो आई हैव ओपन इट। इट विल टेक सम
टाइम एंड इट विल ओपन। ठीक है?
ओपन हो गया। यह कुछ इस तरीके से। इस तरीके
से वारशक में ट्रैफिक्स ओपन होते हैं। अब
यहां पे क्वेश्चन है व्हिच वाशक फ़िल्टर
कैन यू यूज़ टू नैरो डाउन योर रिजल्ट्स
बेस्ड ऑन एसएमटीपी रिस्पांस कोड। एसएमटीपी
रिस्पांस कोड का कौन सा वायर कौन सा
फ़िल्टर आप वायरशार्क का यूज़ करेंगे। तो
वायरशार्क का वो देख लेते हैं। फ़िल्टर
वायरशार्क की वेबसाइट पे वायर शार्क
एसएमटीपी फ़िल्टर्स देख लेते हैं कौन-कौन
से अवेलेबल हैं। तो वायरशार्क का अह विककी
आ गया मतलब इसका तो इसमें
अ
एक तो एसएमटीपी है ये वाली नहीं यार इनका
एक ओर इनका जो होता है ना जो मेन है
डिस्प्ले फिल्टर्स हां डिस्प्ले फिल्टर्स
जो है एसएमटीपी के ये ओपन कर लेते हैं
हमारे साथ की वेबसाइट पे मिल जाएगी तो कौन
सा हमें चाहिए हमें चाहिए एसएमटीपी
रिस्पांस कोड से रिलेटेड कौन सा है
एसएमटीपी रिस्पांस कोड तो रिस्पांस कोड
सर्च कर लेते हैं रिस्पांस यह रहा तो
एसएमटीपी रिस्पांस कोड ये फिल्टर है smtp
डॉट रिस्पोंस डॉट कोड तो यही है एसएमटीp
डॉट रिस्पोंस डॉट कोड
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है डन हाउ मेनी पैकेट्स इन द कैप्चर
कंटेंस द एसएमटीपी रिस्पांस कोड 220
सर्विस रेडी तो एसएमटीपी रिस्पांस कोड 220
सर्विस रेडी कितने पैकेट्स के लिए है यहां
पे तो मैं यहां पे करता हूं एसएमटीपी
रिस्पांस कोड एंड यहां पे इज़ इक्वल टू इज़
इक्वल टू अ क्या करते हैं क्या है भाई
220 तो 220 के लिए
220 के लिए कितने हैं भाई? तो मैंने यह कर
दिया। ये सारे अब 220 वाले आ गए। तो आप
देख सकते हैं एसएमसीटी रिस्पांस को 220
हमने फ़िल्टर किया है। तो इसमें हमें पैकेट
टोटल पैकेट तो 1637 है। नीचे यहां दिख रहे
हैं। 1637 बट डिस्प्लेड है 19 यानी 19 220
के पैकेट्स हैं। आप ऐसे कर लो या इसको
सेलेक्ट ऑल कर लो। तो यहां पे डिस्प्लेड
19 है यहां पे। ठीक है? तो यहां पे 19
हमारा करेक्ट आंसर हो जाएगा।
ठीक है। वन एसएमटीपी रिस्पांस इंडिकेट्स
दैट एन ईमेल वाज ब्लॉक्ड बाय स्पैम.
ईमेल को स्पैम. से ब्लॉक कर दिया गया है।
व्हाट रिस्पांस कोड डड द सर्वर रेटर? कौन
सा रिस्पांस कोड? तो स्पैम.
यह कहां पे है भाई? वन एसएमटीपी रिस्पांस।
एक एसएमटीपी रिस्पांस जो है यह बोलता है
कि स्पैम होस्ट. तो देखते हैं भाई स्पैम
हॉर्स वाली कौन सी है। कोई है क्या स्पैम
हॉर्स करके कुछ
चलो तो ये एसएमटीपी का है तो सिर्फ हम
एसएमटीपी करते हैं एसएमटीपी जरूरी थोड़ी
ना है 220 220 पे ही हो स्पैम हॉर्स अ ये
वाला है क्या
अ स्पैम हॉर्स लेट्स सी आप ऐसे सर्च भी कर
सकते हो इसको स्पैम होस्ट से रिलेटेड ना
आप यहां पे आके यहां पे फाइंड का ऑप्शन
आएगा फाइंड अप कीजिए यहां पे अ इस पे करिए
कंट्रोल एफ कीजिए इसमें फ़्टर में फ़्टर पे
जाइए यहां पे यहां पे कंट्रोल F कीजिए एंड
यहां पे
जस्ट अ सेकंड
ओके
मैं एसएमटीबी को फिल्टर करता हूं यहां पे।
दिस मैसेज वाज़ ब्लॉक्ड। ये रहा
स्पैम हॉर्स वाली है क्या ये?
क्वेश्चन इज कि वि वन एसएमटी रिस्पांस
इंडिकेट्स दैट द ईमेल वाज़ ब्लॉक्ड बाय
स्पैम.
ठीक है?
व्हाट रिस्पांस
कोड तो स्पैम हॉल एसएमडीपी का कुछ है
क्या? रिस्पांस
कोड एक्सपेक्टेड एसएम पैरामीटर
एसएमटीपी रिस्पांस पैरामीटर हम पैरामीटर
भी दे सकते हैं वैसे तो
ठीक है बट स्टिल यहां पर हमने एसएमटीपी का
किया अब यहां देखते हैं स्पैम ऑर्स वाला
कौन सा है भाई
रिस्पांस में एसएमटीपी एसएमटीपी स्पैम ओस
मेल आपको देखना है स्पैम ओस करके
कोई है क्या
देन ओनली वी कैन फाइंड
स्पैम डोमेन आपको दिखे तो बताइएगा।
शॉक media ये तो कुछ और है।
अ स्पैम स्पैम हो
लेट्स फाइंड आउट स्पैम हॉर्स
जस्ट स्पैम हो
एसएमटीपी रिस्पांस ही तो है। एसएमटीp
रिस्पांस
चलो एसएमटीp डॉट रिस्पांस कोड देख लेते
हैं। डॉट रिस्पांस
अह
डॉट कोड कर लेते हैं। इसमें शायद आपको मिल
जाए एसएमडीपी रिस्पांस कोड ओनली वाले में
अगर देखते हैं तो लेट्स सी इफ वी कैन गेट
स्पैम
स्पज
एक ही आ रहा है ब्लॉक्ड
तो कुछ और है स्पैम
आई वांट टू फाइंड द डोमेन जो स्पैम हॉर्स
है वह हमें फाइंड करना है। सो रिलेटेड टू
दैट
सो दिस इज़ द डिस्प्ले फ़िल्टर स्ट्रिंग का
हम करते हैं और यहां पे सर्च कर लेते हैं
स्पैम सॉरी यहां पे हम इस टर्म को सर्च कर
लेते हैं। इस डोमेन को सर्च कर लेते हैं।
स्पैम.
इफ दैट इज़ अवेलेबल एनी तो हम डायरेक्ट
एसएमटीp में ओनली सर्च करते हैं। ठीक है?
हम क्या करते हैं? ओनली एसएमटीपी में सर्च
कर लेते हैं। लेट्स चेक इट।
ठीक है? एंड यहां पे स्ट्रिंग सर्च करते
हैं। एंड यहां पैकेट डिटेल्स पे जाके पहले
तो हम पैकेट लिस्ट करके पैकेट डिटेल्स पे
ही चलते हैं। एंड यहां पे सर्च कर लेते
हैं स्ट्रिंग।
क्या नाम है? स्पैम.
Spam hos.org
कुछ है क्या यहां पे? हां ये रहा। यह मिल
गया। अगर आपको कुछ नहीं मिल रहा हो तो यू
कैन डायरेक्टली सर्च इन हियर। तो स्पैम
ईमेल ब्लॉक्ड ये रहा ना यूजिंग द स्पैम
हाउस। तो ये मिल चुका हमें। सो व्हाट इज द
अ क्या है? व्हाट व्हाट रिस्पांस कोड डिड
द सर्वर रिटर्न? तो स्पैम रिस्पांस कोड
क्या है भैया? इसका 553 है। तो इसका
रिस्पांस कोड है 553। यहां पे आप आपको दिख
रहा होगा यह वाला। यह वाला यह वाला यह
जहां पे राइट क्लिक किया मैंने किया। इस
553 रिस्पांस कोड है। तो हम यहां पे 55 3
कर देंगे। चेक करेंगे।
करेक्ट। बेस्ड ऑन द पैकेट फ्रॉम द
प्रीवियस क्वेश्चन। ठीक है? व्हाट इज द
फुल रिस्पांस कोड मैसेज? अब इसी पे इसी का
जो है रिस्पांस कोड फुल रिस्पांस कोड
मैसेज क्या है? तो जब भी आपको कोई फुल
डिटेल देखनी हो किसी भी एक पैकेट का तो आप
इस पे राइट क्लिक करेंगे और यहां पे फॉलो
पे क्लिक करके टीसीp स्ट्रीम को फॉलो
करेंगे। इसके टीसीp स्ट्रीम को फॉलो
करेंगे तो आपको यहां पे डिटेल यहां पे आ
जाएगी। तो फुल रिस्पांस कोड यहां पे क्या
है भैया? तो लेट्स चेक व्हाट इज द फुल
रिस्पांस कोड।
किसके लिए है यहां पर बेस्ड ऑन द पैकेट
फ्रॉम द प्रीवियस क्वेश्चन। ठीक है? व्हाट
इज द फुल रिस्पांस कोड मैसेज
मेल फ्रॉम सी इतना फिल रिस्पांस कोड ये तो
है नहीं यार रिस्प कौन सा हमारे हमारे पास
था कौन सा ये था ना हां तो ये रिस्पांस
कोड ये रहा रिस्पांस रिस्पांस कोड ये रहा
एक्शन ये रहा ये रहा इस पे आप आएंगे
रिस्पांस पे यहां पे आ रहा है सिंपल मेल
ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल में यहां पे यहां पे आ
रहा है रिस्पांस कोड तो रिस्पांस कोड कोड
में रिक्वेस्टेड एक्शन नॉट टेकन मेल बॉक्स
नेम ऐसे करके। तो मैं यहां पे फॉलो टीसीपी
स्ट्रीम करता हूं। तो इसको यहां पे अ
चलो यहां पे मैं रिस्पांस पे आता हूं। एंड
इसको देखते हैं। फॉलो करके टीसीपी स्ट्रीम
ये क्या आ रहा है यार? एक ही चीज़ क्यों आ
रही है?
एसएमटीपी के स्ट्रीम को फॉलो कर। ये कुछ
यहां पे कुछ तो हो रहा है। चलो हम यहीं से
कॉपी कर लेते हैं। कोई बात नहीं। यह रहा
रिस्पांस कोड और यह रहा इसका फुल वो
रिस्पांस जो आ रहा है रिक्वेस्ट नॉट टेकन
ऐसे करके। तो कॉपी कर लेते हैं। यहां पे
वैल्यू कॉपी कर लेते हैं। एंड यहां पे
इसकी वैल्यू अरे यार
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
यहां पे रिक्वेस्ट नॉट टेकन राइट क्लिक
यहां पे कॉपी कर लेते हैं। सॉरी यहां कॉपी
कर लेते हैं। यहां पे डिस्क्रिप्शन ही
पूरी कॉपी कर लेते हैं। रिक्वेस्ट नॉट
फॉललोड। ये पूरी यहां से ये रही हमारी।
यही है शायद रिक्वेस्ट नॉट हां चेक करते
हैं। यही है रिक्वेस्ट एक्शन नॉट टेकन।
मेल बॉक्स नेम नॉट अलाउड। यह पूरा फुल था।
ये हमने कर लिया। सर्च फॉर द रिस्पांस कोड
552। हाउ मेनी मैसेजेस वेर ब्लॉक्ड फॉर
प्रेजेंटिंग पोटेंशियल सिक्योरिटी इशूज़?
तो 552 रिस्पांस कोड सर्च करना है। तो
सिंपल है यहां पे अगेन अ एसएमटीपी
रिस्पांस कोड 552 यहां 220 की जगह 552 डाल
दीजिए भाई। अ 552
एंटर कर दीजिए। तो कितने हैं भैया?
डिस्प्ले छह। छह हैं टोटल तो सिक्स कर
देंगे। दैट्स इट हो गया। बस सॉल्व हो गई
ये चीज। सिंपल राइट तो यह हमारा था भैया
एसएमटीपी रिस्पांस को एनालिसिस करने का एक
तरीका जिसमें हमने एनालिसिस किया है। फिर
इंस्पेक्ट ईमेल एंड अटैचमेंट्स यहां पे आ
रहे हैं। अ ईमेल एंड अटैचमेंट्स को
इंस्पेक्ट करते हैं। अब देखो यहां पे क्या
है? ईमेल अटैचमेंट इंस्पेक्ट वाले में
चलते हैं। इन दिस टास्क यू विल मूव बियड द
एसएसटीपी स्टेटस कोड्स एंड रेस्पों्ससेस
एंड बिगिन एनालाइजिंग द एसएमटीपी ट्रैफिक
यूजिंग द सेम ट्रैफिक कैप्चर फ्रॉम द
टास्क अबव। सेम टास्क वो रहेगा। यू विल
यूटिलाइज इंटरनेट मैसेज फॉर्मेट आईएमएफ टू
एग्जामिन द इनर डिटेल्स ऑफ ईमेल्स सच एज
सेंडर रेिपिएंट फेल्स कंटेंट टाइप एंड
में। तो हम आईएमएफ का यूज़ यहां पे करने
वाले हैं। ठीक है? इंटरनेट मैसेज फॉर्मेट
जिससे ईमेल के अंदर के इनसाइड डिटेल्स के
बारे में पता चलता है। तो हाउ मेनी
एसएमटीपी पैकेट्स आर अवेलेबल फॉर
एनालिसिस? टोटल एसएमटीपी पैकेट्स कितने
हैं एनालिसिस के लिए अवेलेबल? ठीक है
भैया? तो एसएमटीपी
करो और एंटर कर दो। तो कितने पैकेट्स हैं
भाई एनालिसिस के लिए? एसएमटीपी के लिए
ओनली 512 1637 टोटल है। बट एसएमडीपी के
लिए डिस्प्लेड 512 हो गए हैं। तो 512 यहां
पे अवेलेबल है। व्हाट
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] इज द नेम ऑफ
द अटैचमेंट इन पैकेट 270? तो पैकेट 270
में कौन सा है? तो 270 पे चलते हैं। यहां
पे एसएमटीपी वाले में 270 में पैकेट कौन
सा है? तो 270 ये रहा 270। इसमें पैकेट का
नाम क्या है भाई? तो पैकेट में यहां पे
मैं नीचे की तरफ चलता हूं। तो यहां पे
हैक्स वाले में आपको पैकेट का नाम मिल
जाएगा। यहां पे ये यहां से आप ले लो। ये
रहा फाइल नेम जो है डॉक्यूमेंट डॉट जिप या
तो आप अ यहां अ जस्ट अ सेकंड
यहां पे आप नीचे की तरफ आओगे। अह सिंपल
मेल ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल एसएमटीपी को इस
लाइन बेस टेक्स्ट डाटा को जब एक्स
एक्सपैंड करोगे तो आप नीचे की तरफ आओगे तो
यहां पे फाइल नेम डॉक्यूमेंट डॉट जिप लिख
जाएगा आपको। तो यहां पे फाइल का नाम है
डॉक्यूमेंट डॉट जिप डॉक्यूमेंट डॉट जिप हो
गई सॉरी अकॉर्डिंग टू द मैसेज इन पैकेट
270 270 में जो अ मैसेज है व्हिच होस्ट
IPपी एड्रेस इज़ नॉट रेस्पोंडिंग मेकिंग द
मैसेज अनडिवरेबल कौन सा होस्ट का IPपी
एड्रेस जो है वो मैसेज अनडिवरेबल के वो कर
रहा है तो 270 में ही है तो देख लेते हैं
भाई कौन सा आईपी एड्रेस है भाई जो अनडिवबल
वाला कर रहा है तो फेल दिस मैसेज ठीक है
मैसेज नॉट डिलीवर्ड इन फाइव डेज। ठीक है?
ठीक है? तो, यह हो गया। अब यह आईपी की
डिटेल्स आईपी वाले में यहां पे आईपी वाले
डिटेल्स में चलते हैं। कौन सी भाई होस्ट
आईपी है भैया? हमारी एक बार देख लेते हैं।
यह तो हमारी सोर्स और डेस्टिनेशन है।
हटाओ। टीसीp वाले में चलते हैं।
दिस इज द
होस्ट का आईपी कहां गया भाई?
नेट गियर अच्छा नेट गियर का हैवलेट हैवट
हैवलेट हैवलेट नेट गियर ठीक है
ओके
सो आईपी दिस वन दिस वन कौन से पैकेट के
लिए है ये अकॉर्डिंग टू द मैसेज इन पैकेट
270 270 वाले ही तो है ना 270 पे ही तो है
हम हां 270 पे है तो हम इसको ऐसे करते हैं
270 पे है इस पे ऐसे नहीं समझ में आया
आपको तो राइट क्लिक कर दीजिएगा फॉलो कर
दीजिएगा टीसीp स्ट्रीम पे आपको सारी सारी
जानकारी मिल जाएगी। तो TCP स्ट्रीम पे
आपको सारी जानकारी मिल गई। अब यहां पे
आपको जो IPपी एड्रेस है वो आपको देखना है।
कौन सी IPपी एड्रेस है जो रिसोंसिबल है।
लेट्स सी द आईपी एड्रेस
नॉट अनडिवर्ड। ठीक है।
आईपी एड्रेस कहां है भाई इसकी?
आईपी एड्रेस दिस वन इज द आईपी एड्रेस वन
नहीं ये तो नहीं है ना आईपी एड्रेस हमारा
कौन सा है यार आ जाओ जल्दी आ जाओ
मुजीला
नेक्स्ट पार्ट इज़ द फॉलोइंग मैसेज वाज़
डिलीवर ठीक है हां ये रहा योर मैसेज वाज़
नॉट डिलीव्ड विद इन फाइव डेज यहां पे
होस्ट दिस इज़ नॉट रेस्पोंडिंग तो टीसीपी
स्ट्रीम में थोड़ा देखने थोड़ा टाइम आपको लग
सकता है तो यह होस्ट है जो रिसोंड नहीं कर
रहा है। तो मैं इस होस्ट की यहां पे यह
वाला IPपी एड्रेस है कॉपी कर लेता हूं एंड
यहां पे पेस्ट करके चेक कर लेते हैं। सही
है? बाय फिल्टरिंग फॉर आईएमएफ व्हिच ईमेल
क्लाइंट वाज़ यूज्ड टू सेंड मैसेज कंटेनिंग
द अटैचमेंट अटैचमेंट एससीआर अटैचमेंट एसआर
तो आईएमएफ फ़िल्टर करते हैं यहां पे सर्च
ही करना पड़ेगा इस बार। तो आईएमएफ
ठीक है और अटैचमेंट अगेन सर्च कर लेते
हैं। अटैचमेंट
ठीक है ये रहा अटैचमेंट एससीआर कहां गया
भाई ये क्या अटैचमेंट वाली हां तो ये
अटैचमेंट एससीआर वाली फाइल है अब इसमें
कौन सा क्या बोल रहे हैं ये कौन सा अ में
ईमेल क्लाइंट यूज़ हो रहा है तो ईमेल
क्लाइंट तो राइट क्लिक करके फॉलो tcp
स्ट्रीम तो भैया ईमेल क्लाइंट कौन सी यूज़
हो रही है इसमें
यह तो रहा Microsoft आउटलुक एक्स मेलर X
मेलर जो आपका हेडर है इसमें आपको ईमेल
क्लाइंट के बारे में जानकारी होती है। तो
ईमेल क्लाइंट आपका Microsoft आउटलुक वाला
जो है यूज़ में आ रहा है। सो लेट्स पुट ऑन
द Microsoft आउटलुक चेक। बिल्कुल सही है।
यही है। व्हिच टाइप ऑफ़ इनकोडिंग इज़ यूज़्ड
फॉर दिस पोटेंशियली मैलेशियस अटैचमेंट? तो
इसमें भी आपको इनकोडिंग मिल जाएगी।
ट्रांसफर कंटेंट टाइप यहां पे आपको दिख
रहा होगा। ट्रांसफर कंटेंट ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग मिल ये नहीं यार अ
ये रहा
वेयर इज़ द इनकोडिंग भाई हां कंटेंट
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग ये तो उसका है ना
अटैचमेंट सी इसका देखना है ना अपने को
अटैचमेंट वाले को अटैचमेंट एससीआर का
देखना है ये तो दूसरा है तो इसका जो
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग है वो है बेस 64
तो बेस 64 कॉपी मार लेते हैं हम। आई होप
कि यही हो। यही होगा। हां, डन हो गया। बस
हो गया। दैट्स इट। कहानी समाप्त यहां पे।
अब यहां पे है हाउ ऑर्गेनाइजेशन स्टॉप
फिशिंग एड्रेस। फिशिंग वगैरह। तो ये पढ़
लीजिएगा आप लोग। सिंपल सा है। फिशिंग को
रोकने का तरीका।
यह चीजें बंद कर देता हूं मैं। इसकी अब
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है आपको। यहां से क्लोज
कर देते हैं। मशीनंस को टर्मिनेट कर देते
हैं।
ठीक है? तो जब फिशिंग को रोकने का तरीका
है, टेक्निकल डिफेंसेस होते हैं। ईमेल
फिल्टरिंग होती है। फिल्टरिंग बेस्ड ऑन
आईपी और रेपुटेशन डोमेन का ब्लॉक करना,
अलऊ करना यह होता है। आईपी के लिए सिक्योर
ईमेल गेटवेज होते हैं। एससीजीस होते हैं।
बहुत सारे सिक्योर सिक्योर ईमेल गेटवेज
होते हैं जिनको यूज़ किया जाता है।
एंटीवायरसेस की तरह है। लिंक रीाइटिंग है।
जो भी सस्िशियस यूआरएल और अह लिंक्स हैं
उसको सेफ रीडायरेक्टेड वंस गिव्स द सिस्टम
टाइम टू स्कैन एंड वेरीफाई द लिंक। तो
सिस्टम को टाइम दीजिए और उन लिंक्स को आप
रिप्लेस कर दीजिए सैंड बॉक्सिंग कि कोई भी
ईमेल को आप सैंड बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट में
जैसे कि मैंने आपको बताया था जैसे एनी रन
हो गया या वायरस टोटल जैसे प्लेटफार्म पे
आप लाइक उसको चेक आउट कर सकते हैं
बेसिकली। तो ऐसे सैंड बॉक्स एनवायरमेंट
में आप उसको ओपन कीजिए। ठीक है? यूजर
फेसिंग टूल्स एंड ट्रेनिंग। अब इसके लाइक
अ कुछ यूजर फेसिंग टूल्स एंड ट्रेनिंग्स
हैं जो बहुत सारे लाइक अ बहुत सारे टूल्स
हैं, टेक्निक्स हैं जिसको यूज़ में लिया
जाता है फिशिंग को बेसिकली प्रिवेंट करने
के लिए। फिशिंग स्टेमुलेशन के लिए टूल जो
है आपको मैंने पहले ही बताया था कि एक फिश
टूल तो है ही। फिश टूल। ठीक है? यह एक
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है। उसके अलावा एक
गो फिश करके भी है जो ईमेल फिशिंग
स्टैमुलेशन टूल है। ओपन सोर्स फिशिंग
सेमुलेशन ये टूल है। आप इसको अपने पास
इसको होस्ट कर सकते हैं। इसको यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। इट इट विल बी इंटरेस्टिंग। काफी यह
बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट है। आपको कोई पैसा
नहीं देना है। एकदम फ्री है। यह बहुत ही
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है। गो फिश। इसको जरूर आप
ट्राई कीजिएगा, डिप्लॉय कीजिएगा। एंड अगर
ऐसी ही लाइक कभी ऐसा हो सकता है कि वीडियो
के थ्रू हम इसके बारे में आपको बता भी
दें। आपको डेप्लॉयमेंट वगैरह का सब कुछ
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन दे दें। राइट? तो आपको मजा
भी आएगा। ठीक है? एंड क्लासेस जो एसओसी के
क्लासेस या कोई भी जो सीरीज चलती है उनकी
क्लासेस रिलेटेड उन कुछ टॉपिक्स से
कनेक्टेड अगर कोई अ टॉपिक्स के वीडियोस
लाने होंगे तो हम उसको एज अ वीडियो नॉट एज
अ लाइव क्लास लेकर भी आपके सामने लाएंगे
और आपके सामने वो पेश करेंगे। ठीक है?
दैट्स इट। सो इट वास क्लियर इट्स डन नाउ
यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं क्या है सिक्योरिटी
टीम कुछ कुछ होगा व्हाटएवर
ठीक है तो यहां पे हम इसको मैं क्लोज कर
देता हूं इट्स डन नाउ राइट प्रीमियम बुक
लैब था तो आपको मैंने कंप्लीट कर दिया है
एंड दिस सेशन एंड्स हियर यहीं पे ये सेशन
समाप्त होता है एंड यहां पे मैं चैट पॉप
अप कर लेता हूं और टॉप फैंस की एक बार
लिस्ट देख लेते हैं जो हम हर हर सेशन में
देखते हैं। तो ये हमारे टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट
है। एंड वहीं यूजुअल
नोन नेम्स एंड नोन यूजर हैंडल्स देखने को
मिल रहे हैं। बेसिकली अच्छा है। काफी
अच्छा लगा। दैट्स ग्रेट। ये 50 लोग जो
टॉफेंस में आते हैं। एंड आप सभी का
बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद आज की क्लास में आने के
लिए। एंड आप इन वीडियोस को प्लीज
जाते-जाते लाइक ठोक के जाइए। वीडियो को
शेयर कीजिए। वीडियो जब रिकॉर्डिंग देखिएगा
तो हाइप का बटन आता है। हाइप पे प्रेस
कीजिए। हाइप जितना वीडियो को करते हैं
YouTube उस वीडियो को उतना ही रिकमेंड
करता है। आगे सजेस्ट करता है। ब्रॉडर
ऑडियंस तक पहुंचाता है। तो एक एसओसी सीरीज
फ्री में इतनी इंटरेस्टिंग सीरीज आपको चल
रही है। तो सिर्फ अपने तक आपको नहीं रखना
है। आपको दूसरों की भी हेल्प करनी है।
नॉलेज बढ़ती है शेयरिंग करने से, शेयर
करने से तो आप अपनी नॉलेज को शेयर कीजिए।
लोगों तक पहुंचाइए। इस वीडियो को मैक्सिमम
ऑडियंस तक पहुंचाइए। दैट्स इट। जितना आप
शेयर करेंगे, लोगों तक पहुंचेगी एंड इन
सीरीज को, वीडियोस को लोग देख पाएंगे।
दैट्स इट। सो अगेन थैंक यू वेरी मच एंड हम
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में बहुत जल्दी।
कल आ रही है हमारी एथिकल हैकिंग की
कंप्लीट कोर्स जो कंप्लीट 5:30 घंटे की एक
वन शॉट वीडियो कोर्स है। उस पे अपना प्यार
जरूर दिखाइएगा। जितना शेयर कर सकते हैं,
कमेंट कर सकते हैं, लाइक सब कर दीजिएगा।
हाइप कर दीजिएगा मजा आ जाएगा। सो 6:00 बजे
के आसपास आपको मिल जाएगी। ठीक है? दैट्स
इट। सो, अब
हम इस सेशन को एंड करते हैं। थैंक यू वेरी
मच। एंड हैव अ शुभ रात्रि। गुड नाइट। टेक
केयर एवरीबडी।